hello everyone welcome to the September
2023 ask me anything edition of the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll we are approaching it occurs to
me episode
250 of the mindscape podcast I just
published 248 last week and I'm not
gonna do anything special for the 250th
episode doesn't seem quite glorious
enough to do it but we have
approximately 50 episodes per year uh so
it reminds me that we just passed our
fifth anniversary at the beginning of
July and I didn't do anything as far as
I remember it was a hectic time the
beginning of July I was trying to get my
book done traveling a little bit Etc so
I want to do at least spread some thanks
some gratitude for everyone who's been
listening all the new listeners too but
everyone who has uh enjoyed mindscape
over the last five years that's a lot of
episodes it's not exactly 50 per year
because the amas don't get numbered
things like that but it's pretty
impressive I would not necessarily have
bet five years ago that we'd still be
doing this now certainly not every
single week but it's a lot of fun for me
to do it's a little bit of work I will
not lie about that but I think it's
absolutely worthwhile so far I'm
learning a lot that's for sure I'm
hoping that other people are learning
something too I it's absolutely the case
that part of my motivation for doing
this is to
counteract some of the misinformations
of the bad information that is out there
I know that mindscape is not the most uh
controversial or action-packed or even
you know gee whiz my podcast out there
but there's a lot of cool ideas to talk
to I mean just the fact that I don't
like to have the same guests on more
than once there's a huge number of
guests that I've had that would be great
to have back but there's also an even
Huger number of people who I've not yet
had as guests if be easier for me to
have guests on over and over again no
doubt about that but I never know when
I'm going to discover something new and
interesting but just having someone who
I've never talked to you know most of
the guests by now that I have on
mindscape are people who I've not really
interacted with very seriously before
having them on the podcast so that's
what learning and surprise is all about
you know some episodes will resonate
with some people and some won't but
that's part of the excitement so very
proud of what we've done here very proud
of having uh the mindscape big picture
scholarship which you can donate to that
is helping people study the Big Ideas at
University uh very very pleased that
people sign up for patreon as you know
if you're a listener these ask me
anything episodes are funded by patreon
supporters and they are the ones who are
asking the questions you can become a
patreon supporter it's pretty easy to do
at patreon.com Sean M Carroll and you
know five years is a long time we'd
still be doing it five years from now I
bet we bar I I think so I think it's
it's still uh not run out of things to
do yet at some point if I think that I'm
it's just work then I will quit you know
then I will let easily say like this
isn't worth it anymore but you know five
years uh I I think that there's two
mindscape guests who have uh are
deceased now which is very sad to me uh
herb dentist I think I mentioned before
passed away earlier this year he let
along in a productive life but also Mari
rooty uh has passed away she's exactly
my age we knew each other back in
graduate school
um but cancer does not care how old you
are and she fought cancer for a couple
of years and then eventually as often
happens the continued very harsh
treatments of the cancer were what ended
up
um
uh not being able to be treated anymore
and so she passed away a couple months
ago
um very sad but you know life is going
on right uh if you haven't listened to
mari's episode it's a special one
because it's a bit of a departure from
what we did on mindscape uh otherwise
but she was a uniquely good person at
making a different kind of thing
palatable and exciting and interesting
to other audiences in this case lacanian
psychoanalysis which is not our Forte
here but I couldn't think of a better
person to talk about it than uh Mari and
you know she's very very missed by her
friends and I hope that uh I hope that
she recognized before she died how loved
she was around the world and it's you
know part of time passing is going to
happen to all of us so it's just a
reminder that we've been around for a
while now doing the podcast again
tremendous thanks for everyone listening
uh either if it's completely passively
or supporting the podcast leaving
reviews on iTunes or supporting on
patreon or leaving comments on the
webpage at Preposterous Universe I thank
you all for participating in the journey
it's a great one and we're going to
continue on for a while so with that
let's go
[Music]
thank you
Jason ricciardi says I've heard you
mentioned that Twitter is dying several
times on mindscape and I was wondering
why you feel that way and what do you
think about it now that it's rebranding
to X
uh yeah this is obviously a big
important question I I kind of uh
simply say Twitter's dying and I go on
with it I don't want to dwell on it but
okay this is a perfectly good question
let me give you my thoughts as of
September 2023 subject to change of
course if things change yeah I do think
it's dying it won't it won't completely
die of course that I think is an
exaggeration Twitter will exist uh even
though it's been branded X whatever it's
going to be called it will exist I think
in the years to come at least as long as
this podcast does would be my guess but
it's changing and it's absolutely
changing for the worse uh in many
noticeable ways you know the most
obvious way is this it's much easier to
be an on Twitter now than it
used to be uh it's easier to be racist
or anti-semitic or just basically
combative uh you can see in the people
who were previously banned and invited
back it's not hard to see the general
trend of who has been invited back after
having been gotten rid of Donald Trump
one of the most obvious examples there
and more importantly to me because you
know the the people there are people on
Twitter who are harassed right
um for very in various ways and I'm
generally not one of them I'm not really
a target of harassment but I don't like
it that other people are harassed it
sort of lowers the tone makes it less
Pleasant overall and I feel bad for the
people who are harassed and I'm not the
only person who feels that way and
therefore a lot of the good people who I
like on Twitter have left or are leaving
or are using it less I'm still there but
I use it a lot less I basically you know
post announcements for new podcasts and
I occasionally retweet things but I
don't engage a lot like I used to it's
just a little bit less Pleasant many of
the people like I follow like I said
have literally closed their accounts
there was recently an article I think in
nature about scientists leaving
something like 40 of scientists polled
said that they'd either left Twitter or
were using it a lot less now so you know
that just makes the platform less
enjoyable Less Fun Etc so looking for
Alternatives is the current mode that
I'm in there's another article by the
way I think Washington Post maybe that
that mentioned it's there's a lot more
disinformation on Twitter now than there
ever was before anyhow these are these
are studies these are people collecting
data this is not Vibes this is not you
know an anecdotal impression we all have
our own thing that we see right our own
timeline on social media so your
experience might be great but you can't
extrapolate from your experience to
somebody else's and many people have a
much less great experience right now and
that just means that the conversations
are are not as good and and obviously
there is not just an idea that many
people have been welcomed that you don't
want to be interacting with but the way
that the algorithm arranges the
conversations has been dramatically
altered and there's been a lot of inks
build or electrons destroyed about the
blue check mark system for those of you
of you who are not on Twitter bless your
hearts uh there used to be this thing
called being a verified user and you get
a little blue check mark by you and it
was originally because you know people
like Shaquille O'Neal Who was a big
celebrity user in the early days well
it's easy to start a Twitter account and
claim to be Shaquille O'Neal right so
they decided to introduce this idea of
verification that would make sure that
you really were who you claimed to be
and it spread not only to just
celebrities and athletes but to
journalists and politicians and
academics and so forth so that if you
got that little blue check mark you knew
this person was at least who they said
they were you'd have to listen to them
but at least they were somebody and
there was at least some preference given
and this is always where it gets
contentious but there's an algorithm in
Twitter that sorts the order of replies
and shows you suggest posts even if you
don't subscribe to people and being a
verified user was a little bit of a
boost there
so that has gone away now there's still
blue check marks and there's still
called verified users but they have
nothing to do with being competent with
being an authority with being who you
say you are what they have to do with is
you signing up and paying eight dollars
a month but those people are still
boosted in the conversations and it used
to be that there was at least a slight
positive correlation between being a
verified user and being a constructive
addition to the conversation because you
could get verified by for example being
an authority in some subject you know
when news would break when a country
would get invaded or there was a
disaster somewhere and you could go to
the trending topics and click on them it
was useful to do so because there was
some journalist who had spent 20 years
in this country and was on the ground
and could tell you what was going on and
you would had not heard of them before
but you could find them now when you do
that the people who are shown to you are
people who spend eight dollars and those
are not only not positively correlated
with giving useful information they are
actively negatively correlated with
giving useful information some people
who spend the eight dollars to be
verified are of course perfectly
reasonable but many of them are just
people who want to mouth off you know
people who embody the dunning-kruger
effect and so it's become way less
useful and and it's not only less useful
for people like me trying to find news
and New pieces of information but
there's been various degradations of
what is called the API which lets people
use Twitter automatically to you know
post information and things like that so
emergency services or informational
Services find it much harder to use
Twitter you know for me one of the fun
aspects of Twitter was Kelly true love
who posted under true sci-fi had the
these lists of physicists and
astronomers and writers and philosophers
and so forth would make on Twitter and
would make graphs where you know who
followed who and how you could find
people and things like that very very
useful no longer exists on Twitter
because you can't get the information
you can't download it not allowed to
anymore the company has been steadily
but absolutely unmistakenly making it
harder to use Twitter the way that I
read Twitter used to be something called
tweetdeck now that is removed I can't
use it anymore right so that it's just a
much worse experience overall
um the the statement is that going
forward they're going to remove the
ability to block people on Twitter which
is just a disaster I mean it's a true
disaster for people who are harassed but
it's a disaster for people like me who
have to sift through a lot of nonsense
you know to try to find something
interesting so for many many reasons I
think the Twitter is seriously declining
and again it's not just uh you know the
Vibes are bad it's very tangible full
degradation of the experience like a
Vibes based argument would be well I
don't like that they renamed it X versus
Twitter I couldn't care less that they
renamed it X versus Twitter uh I think
that it is a terrible business decision
to give up a free connection to
basically a word that had entered the
English vocabulary on the basis of your
corporation right the idea of tweeting
and retweeting and quote tweeting are
out there as words that people use and
you give up those words that just makes
no sense to me but I don't claim to be a
genius business person so maybe there's
some logic behind there I don't know I
also don't care they can call it
whatever they want it's just much less
useful to me now than it than it was I
don't know what's going to happen next I
am personally spending most of my time
on Bluesky to the extent that I'm doing
anything at all but I can't really push
Blue Sky very hard because it's not open
yet you need to invite to get there
still in beta hopefully it will roll out
to open enrollment very very soon but
honestly the reason I like blue sky the
best is it's not trying to be anything
else it's not trying to improve things
it's basically just Twitter on a
different platform it's it there's tiny
marginal differences that people make a
big deal out of but it's easy to use you
you'll sign up and you use it and it's
kind of like Twitter and that's all I
really want right
um I know there's other options Mastodon
and threads and so forth lots of people
love Mastodon I just didn't like it that
much it's it's something for you know
Mastodon is Twitter for Linux users I
used to I used to have a Linux box on my
desk and you know in my office and
there's a certain kind of person who
loves Linux as an operating system
rather than uh Mac OS or Windows because
they can really get in there and they
can fiddle with it and they can make it
exactly what they want which is great
it's also just much harder to use if
you're not devoted to it and Mastodon
has that feeling for me it's not
friendly to the new users and so I don't
I don't see it being anywhere near the
scale that Twitter is you know again I
could be completely wrong I have no
special Insight on these things but I
think it's a loss Twitter I really do I
think that it was very important to me
you know I've certainly connected with
many of the mindscape guests in the
first time by reading their Twitter
accounts I've met made friends in real
life from Twitter I've learned things by
talking to people on Twitter so it's not
trivial to me I think it's a it's a true
loss and I feel bad but like I said life
goes on things change we adapt and we
move on
next I'm going to group two questions
together Amy Ferguson says your work
often explores profound questions about
the universe I'm curious about your
personal Reflections in your downtime do
you often find yourself contemplating
deeper bigger picture ideas as a matter
of personal interest and has the nature
or frequency of these Reflections
changed from when you were younger
and then Mike Johnson says does the idea
of Eternity ever cause you to break out
in a cold sweat the idea of Eternity is
one of the few things that will make me
lie awake at night staring at the
ceiling trying to make it make sense I
have an overwhelming sense of dread and
confusion when I think about the idea of
there being no end and even if there was
an end what does that even mean I know
when I'm dead I won't have a brain
capable of these thoughts so it doesn't
really matter but for now the idea
scares the bleep out of me so see I
think you see the relationship between
these two questions you know reflecting
on giant bigger picture ideas uh Mike is
a little bit specific about the idea of
Eternity Amy is more open-ended about
different kinds of big picture questions
you know I've always loved thinking
about big picture questions
um do I do it more now that I'm either
older or more educated or it's my
professional job or whatever I don't
think so you know I do think that your
Reflections change I hope that they do
they certainly did for me it's actually
hard to remember to be honest how I
thought about these things when I was 16
years old or whatever because one does
become extremely different in one's
thought processes as you learn things as
you think about your own thoughts and
realize you know that thought really
wasn't that smart
you know we we're always I hope thinking
about our thoughts right thinking about
where we're coming from and hopefully we
can reinterrogate some of the ways in
which different thoughts fit together
and then change our minds
um so certainly I have a much more
sophisticated I think I would like to
say more sophisticated point of view on
these things but I don't think that the
fundamental nature of frequency of these
Reflections has changed uh I want to
know what the universe is what it's made
of how long it's going to last where it
came from our place in the universe I
think about all these things I I did
I've long thought about exactly those
things the idea of Eternity in
particular doesn't bother me no I mean
it's interesting because some people are
bothered by the idea that the universe
will end right the idea that it's not
Eternal bothers some people I think that
bothering or a cold sweat is just a not
quite the right way or the best way to
approach it in the sense that what it is
is what would be better would be an
acknowledgment
that our everyday intuitions trained as
they are by evolution in our lives and
things like that just aren't up to the
task of thinking about eternity Pro or
con right so why should we feel
comfortable and happy thinking about
these questions so even though I like
thinking about these big deep questions
I don't expect that my instincts or
intuition are going to be very helpful
or you know really going to tune me to
think about them in the best way you
really have to try to be open-minded I
think and say like well you know I
thought it should be this way but it
it's not that way uh you know I think
that I it would be more satisfying to me
or more rewarding if it were this way
but it just isn't you know that's that's
the kind of attitude I want to take in
my Reflections on these deepest
questions
Ahmad chaker says I just watched your
video on renormalization this is
referring to from a couple years ago the
biggest ideas in the universe videos
that are leading into the books that
were in the process of putting out so
mod says I think I understand why we can
ignore energies above a certain cutoff
but the loop diagrams still have an
infinite amount of diagrams between
let's say two EV and three EV what
happens to these
good this is a great question actually I
never quite thought about it that way
it's kind of interesting uh version of
uh a way that you can think about it
like I I can say all the words that I'm
saying and they make perfect sense to me
but someone hears them and reinterprets
them in a slightly different but
completely legitimate way and reaches
something else so the idea here just to
back up is infinemin diagrams when
you're calculating some process so
finding diagrams remember are little
pictures of Elementary particles bumping
into each other but they're not just
evocative little pictures the physicists
who do this for a living use Feynman
diagrams to do calculations the diagrams
correspond to a certain equation which
you then typically an integral which you
then solve to figure out what exactly is
the probability of this process
occurring and when you have a loop in a
Feynman diagram so you can imagine the
topology of these little pictures you're
drawing you can draw tree diagrams like
an electron comes in and goes out a
positron goes in and comes out and they
exchange one little Photon between them
there are no Loops there's no closed
Curves in that diagram but if they
exchanged two photons between them now
there's a loop that you can sort of draw
when you go around and the rule and find
the diagram land is you add up the
contributions from every possible
diagram when there is a loop in the
diagram there is a free parameter
because you can ask how much momentum is
going down any one leg of that Loop and
it turns out it is not fixed by the
external conditions by just momentum
conservation Etc so you integrate over
all possible values of the momentum
going through the loop and this integral
will often be infinite if you do it in
the sort of straightforward conventional
follow your nose way this is what led to
all the discussion in the 1940s and 50s
about Infinities and renormalization in
Quantum field Theory Etc and the reason
why it's infinite is is
the correct reason let me say it
correctly first then we'll back up the
correct reason is because you when it is
infinite some Loop diagrams are not
infinite but but many are the reason why
they are is because you're integrating
the momentum going through the loop from
zero to Infinity
and some functions that you integrate
from 0 to Infinity like 1 over x squared
forget zero how about integrating one
into Infinity
there are some functions you can
integrate and get a finite answer okay
but there's other functions I guess
maybe e to the minus X would be a better
example you can integrate that from 0 to
Infinity perfectly well
um there's other functions which you
know the integral gets bigger and bigger
and bigger and just gets you know
infinitely big
so the whole idea of what are called
effective field theories is to put a cut
off on that momentum to not integrate
from zero to Infinity but from zero to
some finite number and then the integral
becomes finite and you can read about
that in my upcoming book quanta and
fields which is the second volume and
the biggest ideas in the universe Series
so anyway ahmad's question is but if you
just look at a finite range of momenta
that you're including so forget about
the infinitely big momentum
I should I should have said that the
justification for ignoring the
infinitely big momenta is we don't know
what's going on that infinitely big
momenta momentum is inversely
proportional to distance in quantum
mechanics and field Theory so you're
effectively talking about infinitely
short distances where space time itself
might not be a valid concept so there's
a justification for doing this
but technically an integral is a sum
over an infinite number of things right
so as a mod correctly says just between
two electron volts and three electron
volts there are an infinite number of
momenta that you're adding up in some
sense the answer which is sort of
disappointingly mundane is that's just
what calculus is for calculus is exactly
about adding up an infinite number of
things and getting a finite answer
because really you're adding up zero
times infinity okay and that's
ill-defined as it is uh simply stated
baldly that way the zero that I'm
talking about is the contribution from a
single number between in this case two
electron volts and three electron volts
it's it's the area under a curve of zero
width right it's the curve that goes
from a certain number to the same number
without moving at all that's going to
have zero area under it but there's an
infinite number of them that we add up
to get the whole area under the curve
between the starting value and an ending
value so it was Newton and leibniz who
taught us how to do this which is to
discretize to Chunk Up that curve into
finite area rectangles add all them up
but then take the limit as the
rectangles get skinnier and skinnier and
by doing that you get a well-defined
limit a finite answer for your infinite
sum it's exactly the same thing in
finding diagrams there's nothing
different than that you get a finite
answer for the integral over this Loop
momentum of all the possible momenta
between 2ev and three EV that's just not
a problem that's just calculus the only
problem comes when you're considering
momentum to go infinitely big and that's
a whole other story
Cooper says has your thinking on
complexity changed at all in light of
your recent conversations with Sam
Bowles and David krakauer both emphasize
the teleological nature of complex
systems and my impression was that you
hadn't thought of that feature being a
fundamental aspect of complexity
well yes and no uh on the one hand I
think that you're right that I well I
guess the way that I would put it is uh
I had not thought that anyone would use
the feature of teleological Behavior or
teleonomic matter as David likes to say
um as a fundamental
characteristic of complex systems it is
certainly a characteristic of some
complex systems and I'm very very
interested in understanding how that can
be the case in a world where the
fundamental laws of physics are not
teleological at all so this is a classic
case asking about emergence right how do
you get purposes and goals emerging out
of the Mindless purposeless interaction
of microscopic subsystems I think that's
a perfectly legitimate question to ask I
think it's perfectly legitimate to say
this is a fundamental problem that we
should focus on I don't think it's right
to say that that's a necessary Central
feature of complex systems
I do think that the Galaxy is complex
you know our galaxy is pretty darn
complex it is not telenomic in any
useful sense so I think that I mean I
get why you would want to do that
because as David would say there is a
such a big difference once matter
becomes teleonomic once
um a complex adaptive system has goals
and you know that's you know back in the
day you would in in Santa Fe Institute
circles hear a lot more talk about
complex adaptive systems than you do now
these days we more often just talk about
complex systems and I think that's an
important difference the if if you stick
the word adaptive in there then I would
absolutely get that teleology is playing
a big role the idea of a complex
adaptive system is that it has
information about the external World it
processes that information and it uses
that information to get something that
in some well-defined sense it wants even
if that thing is just to stay alive to
continue existing right
I think that there are precursors to
that that count as complex and so so my
argument would be that if you skip right
to telenomic matter and uh complex
adaptive systems that have goals and so
forth you're skipping over a lot of
interesting things right I mean you're
you're talking about the evolution of
the species without talking about the
origin of life and you're absolutely
welcome to do that that's a fine thing
to do but you wouldn't want to argue the
origin of life is uninteresting you
wouldn't want to argue I think that the
various kinds of systems that seem
complex to me but don't yet have purpose
or teleology in them are somehow less
interesting or don't count so I'm just I
don't think there's really any
incompatibility here I'm just Plumping
for a more expansive notion of
complexity that it includes the thing
that I care about which is where these
complex systems came to be in the first
place complexogenesis right that's
um something that dovetails very nicely
with my interest in entropy and
thermodynamics and the arrow of time so
I don't want it ruled out from this
whole
area of inquiry
Rob gebola says I have a question about
your confidence in the claim that all
physical laws relevant for our everyday
life are known what about the
possibility of a new Force which is so
weakly coupled that we would not see it
in current collider experiments but
which becomes relevant when very many
particles are involved at mesoscopic or
macroscopic scales after all gravity is
like that and we wouldn't have found it
by only looking at collider experiments
yeah sure a weak new force is absolutely
something that we can be interested in
and look for and are interested in and
do look for if you look up the various
places papers and books and so forth
where I've talked about this idea I
explicitly consider this possibility the
fact is that ordinary matter is made of
only three things at the end of the day
protons neutrons and electrons maybe you
could add in
photons and gluons if you wanted to like
look at a higher order perturbation but
roughly speaking the quantum numbers
that are non-zero from the matter in you
and me are the numbers of electrons the
numbers of protons the numbers of
neutrons so that actually makes it very
simple to look for new weak forces
because all you have to do is measure
the force between electrons protons and
neutrons and other electrons protons
neutrons so the parameter space is kind
of small you can actually do everything
and so all you have to do is look at
heavy collections of matter with
different abundances of protons neutrons
and electrons right people have done
that the there are limits there are
quantitative numerical limits on how big
such a new force can be of course it's
not necessarily the same as gravity
because gravity is what we think of as
an infinite range force it stretches
over astrophysical distances you could
imagine a force that is stronger than
gravity but shorter range so it's not as
obvious in an astrophysical setting but
we've looked for that too and the answer
is if you go down to the scales that are
like
you know neurological scales right the
sizes of uh the separation between
neurons in your brain or something like
that the limits on the strength of any
new Force are comparable I forget the
numbers but you know they're in the same
ballpark as the strength of gravity
and the thing about gravity is it's a
super weak Force like you say we do
notice it but only because all of the
earth is pulling us down so if you care
about the force exerted by a neuron on
another neuron or even by the Earth on
another neuron uh there's just no room
for that uh those are ruled out so yeah
that's that's a absolutely conceptually
allowed thing to think about but the
data have spoken on that one they're not
there there could be other forces there
but they're too weak to uh make any
difference to our everyday lives
including our biology
Chris V says what are your worries and
hopes for the future
um I don't want to say too much about
this because we have an upcoming podcast
about worries and hopes for the future
but I think that you know some of the
worries and hopes for the future are
kind of predictable like there are trend
lines you know uh environmental ones
especially when it comes to climate
change or pollution or things like that
there are Trends and they might look bad
and that's a worry and I think that's a
perfectly legitimate worry but then we
can also work against them my worries
and hopes therefore are actually more
concentrated I guess I'm talking about
the worries right now let's start with
the worries
um the unpredictable things you know the
things that might have a rate or a
probability of happening but we don't
know what it is and it's small okay so
the question when you have something
that would be a disaster but it's
unlikely to happen is how do you balance
a small probability versus a giant
impact if the thing does happen you know
AR is is an example that people like to
use and I'll just repeat my usual thing
that I say about AI uh I think there's
plenty of good reasons to worry about
the impact of AI on our lives and I am
absolutely in favor of worrying about it
and putting safeguards in place I I am
not impressed by people who leap right
to destroying all life on Earth I think
that that is not a very plausible
scenario and if you know there's some
other scenario where a hundred million
people die or even more likely a
scenario where billions of people are
slightly worse off
really bad
worry about that that's that's much more
plausible than extinction level events
and is absolutely worth worrying about
and if we do worry about it
I think we will also ameliorate the
probability of the extinction level
events so I don't think so AI is not
high on my list there because I think
that if we just take the realistic
worries about it
um we at least can try to ameliorate
them whether we will or not yeah that
that I don't know
um I'm kind of more worried to be honest
about things that just seem unlikely but
are not new and sexy like new bio
weapons pandemics good old-fashioned
nuclear war right I think these things
are still quite possible
um again we don't need to jump right to
extinction level events to imagine
millions of people being adversely
affected by them and the time scales you
know the the frequency with which these
things happen are sufficiently rare that
human beings are not good at planning
for them you know it hasn't happened in
the last five years of course the
pandemic thing did I get that but
otherwise you know in a few years we'll
say well it's been a while since the
last pandemic I'm not so concerned about
that one one anymore and human beings
bless their hearts they're just not good
at planning for things like that so it's
those kind of not completely implausible
disaster scenarios that have time scales
longer than 10 years between when they
generally happen that I think are very
good to worry about sunspots and solar
solar flares are another one that I've
talked about before in terms of hopes
you know
I don't know I I have mentioned recently
uh the podcast we did with John Denver
about our coming automated Utopia
um you know I think we're we're getting
very good as a society at
creating wealth creating food creating
power creating knowledge power in the
sense of like electricity and things
like that not political power
um we might even arguably be getting
better at protecting the environment if
we really put our minds to it we have
the capability technologically let's put
it that way to protect the environment I
always go back to the podcast we did
with Joe Walston talking about how just
moving people into cities is a
tremendously beneficial thing to do for
the environment and it is happening
right uh so I can imagine the following
idea this is probably utopian but that's
okay you said what are the hopes I can
imagine that
technology has been improving so quickly
that there's a mismatch in the time
scale between the rate of technological
Improvement and humans habits of mind
that organize society and how quickly
those get updated you know maybe right
now we're still in a medieval mindset
where it comes to society even though we
have a much more abundant
physical environment in which we live so
the idea that we should just take all
this wealth and make sure every person
is fed and housed and has basic health
care and education I think is a feasible
thing we could do it as a certainly in
the United States we could do it if we
wanted to in the world probably we could
do it without too much extra effort but
we don't we don't even try right to
literally like just feed and clothe
everybody that's that's considered I
don't know something that you know
Society isn't isn't meant to do I think
that's an outdated conception so the
utopian in me wants to think that we at
least might contemplate dramatically
shifting how we organize Society so that
everyone is uh you know given some basic
needs we have the physical capacity to
do that it's our choice not to be doing
it right now so my hope is that we catch
on to the fact that we can do it and the
fact that everyone benefits if we do it
if we just make sure there are no
homeless people there's nobody living in
poverty there's nobody who does doesn't
get an education or there's nobody who
dies as a child unnecessarily Etc all
those things we could do those are my
hopes for the future maybe this podcast
you know increases the probability that
it happens by 0.0001 or something like
that that's my single biggest hope for
what what the mindscape podcast can
possibly do
David Maxwell says does tenure for
University positions act as a break on
society's intellectual advancement by
keeping those with old ideas around at
the expense of those with fresh ideas is
it still an appropriate way to allocate
The Limited resource of funded academics
or research positions I think I've
talked about this before so maybe I'll
try to keep it brief but I think yes I
think so because you can't just change
one aspect of a system like this and
expect all the other aspects to go ahead
unchanged if it weren't for tenure why
would most people even try to become
professors you know most people who
become professors spend a lot of time a
lot of years of their lives training for
it they're generally hard workers pretty
effective at the work that they do
they're generally smart cookies and
they're talented and they could make a
living other ways you know even my
literal set of graduate students who I
work with and who I know they either you
know quote unquote succeed by becoming
faculty members or they don't succeed at
becoming faculty members and get much
higher paid jobs doing something else
but a lot of that is a trade-off you
know we say Okay We're not gonna give
you as much money or material rewards as
you might otherwise get but will give
you job security and that's very
attractive to people you know the idea
like I'm gonna work and work and work
and get tenure that's the goal a lot of
these people have and it would be
completely wrong to Discount the more
highbrow fact that
tenure gives you Freedom tenure gives
you the freedom to work on new things
like if I were hired to be a cosmologist
I decided I wanted to work on philosophy
instead if I had tenure which I don't by
the way but I have a different position
which is which is good for other reasons
um I could do that you can switch Fields
you can let your creative Juices Flow
many people have zero desire to let
their creative Juices Flow that's fine
but in many ways tenure is just a simple
set of compromises that keeps Academia
full of smart people working hard on
their things now obviously there's
plenty of people who just kind of chill
out after a while don't work very hard
or not productive you know that's that
is the price you pay very often those
people are useful in other ways whether
it is teaching or Administration or just
being a voice of wisdom that you can
talk to in the seminar room and things
like that so I do I do think that there
should be more
uh
more variety in how these things are
organized that is to say I wish that
different academic institutions didn't
all use the same system so that maybe
some people who kind of liked it one way
could go to different universities or
different research institutes but guess
what this has been tried there have been
universities and research institutes
that have tried to not have tenure
nobody wants to go there or people go
there and say please you know let's
Institute the idea of tenure okay so
it's an incentive for smart people to do
their thing I think it's it's a fairly
good system overall
Paul cousin says is it common to contact
an author to let them know that you
cited their work or do cited authors
usually find out via Google Scholar or
something similar
it is completely uncommon to contact an
author to let them know you cited their
work it's fine you will you know
sometimes get emails with a paper
attached saying hey you know I wrote
this paper it's on something you're
interested in you know maybe you like to
read it whatever that that's completely
okay but it's not the norm it's not
common when I write a paper uh and I
have I don't know 20 30 40 50 citations
in it I do not email all the people who
are in my list of citations in fact it's
it's more than that like I was reading
as I'm uh
recording this I'm preparing a week from
now I'm going to have a public debate
with Philip Goff you remember Philip he
was on the podcast he is one of the
champions of pan psychism out there in
the world right now and uh so we're
having a debate about pan psychism pro
and con and so I was reading a couple of
papers about pan psychism and I read one
and it was literally the whole paper was
a response to me
was a response to my paper on uh
Consciousness and the laws of physics
and I never knew so I was like oh this
is kind of flattering I didn't really
agree with anything that was in the
paper but you know still it's kind of
nice to know that people are taking it
seriously so I don't know maybe maybe
they it should be more common to let
people know
um but maybe you don't want to let
people know when the whole point of your
paper is to say the person is wrong okay
so I think that uh
it it raises an interesting question of
what is the future equilibrium way that
academics and Scholars will find out
about papers that are interesting to
them because there are too many papers
right there's just too many papers to
read if you are uh successful ongoing
researcher who has a research group with
students and postdocs in it then those
students and postdocs are your way of
knowing what is interesting in the
research literature right now they're
the ones who are young and learning and
energetic and are reading everything and
they will tell you if something
interesting comes up
um if you're all by yourself then you
have to do a little bit more work so
Google Scholar you know Google Scholar
by the way not only is a place where you
can go and find out who cited your paper
they will send you a daily update here's
how many people cited your paper here's
all the new papers that cited you so I
do that and it's not you know uh ego
surfing I'm not like oh happy that
someone cited me I want to know if
someone is building on the work that we
did in various interesting ways there's
also semantic scholar which does
something like the same thing but it's
not quite tied to citations it's just
here are papers we think you would be
interested in given what papers you've
written about before so again I don't
think that we're done yet I don't think
that we're in that equilibrium state
where we know the best way for people to
find these things out but hopefully
we're improving the State of Affairs
okay I'm going to group two questions
together uh one is from Fabian rostollen
by the way uh before I actually answer
this I should have said this in the
intro but a couple things number one uh
we're getting a lot of questions and
that call for questions in the amas
these days so the fraction of them that
I get to answer is smaller apologies for
that I make a tiny bit of effort if I
don't recognize someone's name from
previous amas I try to give them a
little bit of preference I'm not very
good at that it's not at all systematic
I'm sorry if you're you know you've been
asking questions and have never gotten
one through my apologies for that but I
do try to spread the wealth a little bit
and the other is I will reiterate the
instructions number one keep your
questions short number two only one
question per AMA so there's some folks
in there that that seem to have not
noticed those instructions but those
instructions help you get a question
answered anyway neither one of these
apply to these questions I don't know
why it just came up into my brain right
now but Fabian says I recently thought
of the fact that when I do something
good for a future person like future me
I'm actually doing something nice for an
incredibly huge amount of future people
on different branches somehow it's made
it even more enjoyable to do something
nice like cleaning the house for my
future selves have you had any
philosophical realizations or something
similar from this way of trying to
understand the self in the context of a
branching universe and the other
question is by gauta eindaval who says
are believers in the many world
interpretation of quantum mechanics
faced with different ethical
considerations than Believers in one
world interpretations it seems to me
that my relationship to a future version
of me on a different brand resembles my
relationship to a person living today
that I will never meet and if so I would
think the joy of dodging a bullet that
could be set up by having a lucky draw
of a Quantum process using the universe
splitter app should be diminished by the
fact that another person on a different
branch was hit by the bullet with a one
world interpretation of quantum
mechanics this would not be so so both
of these have to do with different
levels of seriousness thinking about the
ethical uh implications of the many
worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics for fabian's question I think
this is the more straightforward answer
here
um I do not as a matter of sort of
rigorous scientific understanding think
of the impact of actions I take today on
future Generations any differently
because I believe in many worlds then I
would in ordinary single World classical
or quantum physics and I think that to
be consistent if you're uh if if many
worlds is your favorite Theory that's
how you have to behave so you know we
always talk about deriving the born rule
right deriving the probability rule in
quantum mechanics the idea that the
probability of seeing something is given
by the amplitude squared of the wave
function and there's different arguments
about the best way to do that chip
siebens and I had a way to do it that I
kind of like but the implications go way
further than just deriving the
probability rule the implication is that
the world's count by a certain amount
that is weighted by their wave function
squared so this the short to skip to the
answer here even though there are in
some sense more people in the future
each one of them counts less I don't
mean to you know disparage them but they
count as much as you know a person times
the wave function squared and what that
means is that the total amount of
counting is constant over time it does
not grow just because the universe
splits or subdivides you start with a
very thick branch at the beginning and
it splinters and divides but the total
weight on all the branches remains fixed
I think you have to think that way if
you want to accept many worlds and take
it seriously and move forward with your
life because otherwise
I could do a a Stern gerlock experiment
I could measure a spin of a particle
that was in a 50 50 chance and you know
suddenly it's now uh there's a universe
where it was spin up a universe or a
spin down
and I can do that or I could it could be
done without me knowing let's put it
that way
and if it's done without me knowing then
suddenly there are twice as many people
in the Multiverse because there is a
whole other Universe right and in fact
most Quantum measurements are of exactly
this form I don't know that they're even
going on but it shouldn't affect my
going through life whether someone
somewhere out there in the in the in
space is doing a measurement of a
Quantum system and the only possible way
that it can't is if I think that the
people post measurement count only as
much as them times their wave function
squared that is the consistent way to
accept many worlds as a theory and
therefore I don't think it matters that
there are more people more copies of me
in the future and likewise for gout this
question
um
this idea of
re you know how do you deal with the
reinterpretation of probability in a
many world interpretation versus a
single single stochastic world I think
that any prediction any any way that you
have of dealing with the future world is
I gave examples in something deeply
hidden and so forth that you could
contrive rules that would make you act
differently if many worlds were true
versus if it's not but they're
absolutely contrived they're not very
natural if you think that there's a
probability that something is going to
happen or not in a single World versus
saying both things will really happen
but they are weighted they are weighted
by numbers that add up to one I think
there's no difference in how you act or
think in those two situations and maybe
you think that there should be but then
you shouldn't accept many worlds because
it's not going to work out for you in
various ways
Lothian 53 says in the many worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics how
do we know that the other worlds
continue to exist past the point where
we lose contact with them well we don't
any more than we know that our world
will exist tomorrow right like how would
we know that
we have a prediction on the basis of a
model the prediction of many worlds is
that all the worlds are equally real
they just keep existing the other
world's likelihood of existing from
moment to moment is the same as ours
there's nothing special about it it may
be that we live in a Multiverse where
there's a terrible genocidal evil demon
who lets those worlds come into
existence and then wipes them out of
existence that would be weird and
bizarre and we have no empirical reason
to think that but if you want to think
that you are welcome to do so
ecpw says how do you feel about data
science being accepted as an alternative
to algebra and calculus in higher
education admission requirements
well I have mixed feelings about that
um uh on there's a positive side and a
negative side on the positive side for a
long time I've thought that statistical
reasoning should be uh given much more
weight in uh this is actually not higher
education typically the people are
talking about this it's usually the high
school level that people most care about
this question
um you know we there's only a finite
number of years in high school and
there's a lot of good math to be taught
algebra geometry calculus I think the
statistics also deserves a place at the
table and that means that something has
to go you know whatever that is that
might be different for different people
Etc but I think reasoning about
probabilities and uncertainties is very
very important and is also mathy you
know it doesn't have to be just you know
here's a coin flip so you can get really
deep into serious math and solving
equations uh if you study probability
carefully and I think maybe data science
more broadly same kind of thing how do
you fit a curve to some data how do you
deal with errors and uncertainties and
things like that
Central limit theorems a whole bunch of
very good things that you can absolutely
talk about as part of a respectable math
education that's the good part the bad
part is that there has been a movement
in certain places California for example
to Simply water down the high school
math curriculum and I think that's a
disaster I think that's terrible even
when it's done with the best of
intentions you know some people are
saying well
some students are less prepared than
others and they struggle in math classes
because they're less prepared and guess
what unsurprisingly that lack of
preparation is often correlated with
either socioeconomic status or racial
categories or things like that and it
seems like effectively we're just they
would they would say it seems like we're
discriminating against these students by
making them take the same classes as
people with better preparation
and therefore the conclusion that they
would have that I think is terrible
would be everyone should have less math
or easier math or something like that it
is somehow discriminatory to offer
calculus in high school or to demand
that every student know Algebra I think
that's terrible I think that the way out
of discrimination is not to make
everything easier for people but to give
people the resources to do the hard work
you know if people aren't learning
algebra and calculus as well as they
should dump money on the problem would
be my solution you know the education
system is failing good Make It Stop
failing don't say well it's failing and
therefore let's fail equally that's not
the way to do it uh I think that you
help people who have lived through
discrimination by offering them
opportunities and one of those
opportunities is learn math
that includes data science as well as
algebra and calculus and geometry but if
what you're secretly or not so secretly
doing is date is using data science as a
way to just make things easier and less
rigorous and less challenging and less
mathy so that no one's feelings are hurt
I think that's a huge mistake that
people are making
Ken Wolfe says in the visual arts
entertainment or literature that you
enjoy is there something that you would
regard as comfort food whether it is a
specific work body work or genre is
there something you go back to again and
again not out of respect or admiration
or to gain a new insight but just
because it puts you in your happy place
by way of full disclosure some of mine
are Star Trek anime romantic comedy
romantic comedy and the 1812 Overture
I'm not sure from Ken's um placement of
commas whether anime and romantic
comedies are two separate categories or
one category of anime romantic comedy
both are perfectly plausible answers
there you know absolutely so this is a
perfectly good question and uh I'm a
huge believer in comfort food by the way
both literal comfort food and figurative
comfort food when it comes to eating I'm
a huge believer in comfort food like
when I've had a really long day or a
really long week or whatever it's going
to be pizza and buffalo wings for me and
and uh in past it also would have been
ice cream I'm not as young as I used to
be I can't just wolf down the pint of
ice cream without any ill effects like I
could have when I was in my youth in my
salad days
um but you know I know that the pizza
and the wings are not good for me but
they make me feel better those
endorphins come rushing in and I'm I
think that's perfectly fine
macaroni and cheese whatever it is and I
say that as someone who is also very
willing to eat crazy challenging food
and be rewarded by that but I think that
the variety is good and I feel the same
way about Arts entertainment and
literature in fact you know both
Jennifer and I you know we have a
routine where we work really really hard
during the day and then we kind of
collapse and you know we don't wanna
do anything challenging like you know
we'll read uh of course but usually like
once it's late at night we're reading
fun simple things you know the simplest
things for me the most fun things that
are still rewarding are just you know
reading these science fiction stories or
the science fiction authors that I grew
up with as a kid so Heinlein and zelazny
and Le Guin and the Dragon Riders of
Pern or something like that you know I
could just read that stuff over and over
again and I've discovered newer ones Ian
Banks is really difficult to read the
first time uh but upon rereading it's
fun because you like you're already in
you know what World building has already
happened so I can just reread those
they're rich enough I can reread them
again and again
um and we watch TV we watch a lot of TV
because it's you know fun and you know
whether it's uh poro or Colombo murder
mysteries or you know recently I'll tell
you a story I was recently
as part of Johns Hopkins yeah I should
let me back up even more sorry about
this but look it's my AMA I can tell you
whatever I want so one of the I was
thinking about this the other day one of
the super great things about my new job
here at Johns Hopkins is that I'm really
you know finally at this Advanced age
that I've reached living the dream of
being an interdisciplinary academic
scholar so as you know I am
in Prince in in practice I should say a
member of the physics department at
Hopkins and also the philosophy
department at Hopkins but I'm also with
genen Ismail we founded a natural
philosophy Forum I am also on the
faculty board for something called the
Alexander grass Humanities Institute and
I'm also a faculty affiliate of the SNF
Agora Institute for democracy so and I
have friends and I and potential future
collaborators who are in the engineering
school so I'm I'm not just doing physics
and philosophy I'm engaging with people
who are doing the humanities and
literature and arts people who are doing
the social sciences and democracy people
who are doing engineering and it's just
you know uh like a kid in a candy store
as it were I'm having a enormous time
like finally I feel like an
undergraduate again right I get to think
about all these things and it's not like
that narrow-minded professionalized
hyper-specialized Academia that I can do
fine in it doesn't really make me super
duper happy anyway why am I telling you
this because at the humanities Institute
I ran into and made friends with a woman
in Virginia Jewish who is an Italian
scholar you know she translates Dante
and things like that but she's also a
media scholar she works in the Italian
uh TV industry she helps Italian TV
companies make things so make shows and
so forth
so here in the U.S at Hopkins she told a
course a first year seminar course on
the uh Prestige TV era right like some
of the best TV shows that we have now
and so we were talking about it and she
said yeah she asked her students to
become familiar with five different TV
shows and she said it was The Sopranos
the wire Mad Men Breaking Bad and Jane
the Virgin
and I like apparently every other person
you know response was Jane the Virgin
huh that doesn't fit into the pattern
that has been established with these
other shows and she says yes and I and
when she was telling me this I'd never
seen an episode of Jane the Virgin and
she she said yes it's a very different
kind of show for those of you who don't
know Jane the Virgin was it was a fairly
fairly recently I think it ended 2019 or
something like that uh it was a slight
parody adaptation of a Venezuelan
telenovela the
Spanish-speaking world has this
tradition of telenovelas which are like
hypercharged soap operas right these you
know ridiculous plots secret twins dead
people coming back to life people being
married people being brother and sister
you know all these you know crazy tropes
and so Jane the Virgin is kind of a
not really a parody of like a loving
parody of it let's put it that way in an
American context so now it's set in
Miami it's called Jane the Virgin
because Jane is mistakenly artificially
inseminated with someone else's sperm
and has a baby even though she's still a
virgin okay and it goes on
and uh Ginny explains to me that you
know this show even though it's
extremely light-hearted and fun and it's
basically a comedy dramedy maybe
whatever you want to call it but it hits
a huge number of really deep issues for
one thing it's a bunch of
um immigrants in the United States so
they're dealing with you know it ran
from what like 2015 to 2019 guess who
got elected president of the United
States in that era and that was a there
was a serious set of issues that have
not gone away
um for people who might be undocumented
uh or family members are undocumented
but also questions of uh religion
because Jane and her family are Catholic
questions of you know obviously
premarital sex but then she has the baby
raising a baby questions of abortion
um and it goes on to a whole bunch of
like super serious issues are actually
dealt with in this show but in a kind of
light-hearted and fun way when they're
not tugging on your heartstrings anyway
the point is that we have been watching
Jane the Virgin and just loving it it's
great
um it it but it's but it illustrates
what I wanted to say at the very
beginning but I'm too wordy to get there
uh which is that
even my comfort food I like to be high
quality comfort food it doesn't need to
be challenging right but it needs to be
good like I I cannot watch TV shows or
eat food that is just bad I remember
having a discussion with a friend of
mine uh a little while ago where we
reminisced about how much we love
Kentucky Fried Chicken growing up and I
said yeah I actually you know I did
remember loving it so much I recently
went back and had some Kentucky Fried
Chicken and my friend said oh man was it
really good and I said no it's awful it
was really bad it's just I don't know
whether the quality of Kentucky Fried
Chicken has gone down or whether I have
just changed as a person but just
because something is junky and supposed
to be comforting doesn't mean that it
works so uh even though I have pizza and
wings I I care a lot about the quality
of the pizza and wings even though I
like to watch a silly telenovela TV show
late at night when I'm not in a mood to
be challenged it still has to be quality
right you know surprising intelligent
characters
Etc so
um lots of things like that whether it's
music or or reading or TV but I will I
will close this you clearly asked a good
question I rambled on for a while there
Carlos Nunez says as an economist I
loved your episode with Sam Bowles
economics is famously known as the
Dismal science given that its intention
of offering precise explanation
explanations and making accurate
forecasts often fall short of their
lofty goals do you think that economics
will ever become a true science or will
economists always fail predictions
meanwhile arguing that things couldn't
have been any different after the fact
you know I don't want to give it
economists advice it's a tough thing
anything uh when human beings and are
involved or other complex adaptive
systems it's way harder to make useful
predictions than it is in physics where
you can be spherical Cal about it and
ignore all those complications uh I
think economics is a science I think
political science and sociology are also
Sciences they're just difficult science
is because they involve human beings you
can throw in Psychology and Urban Design
and things like that other things that
we've all talked about here on mindscape
many times
I think that the standards have to be
adjusted to be realistic you know maybe
it will never be the case that
economists will predict when the next
stock market crash will happen but maybe
they will be able to ameliorate the
effects of that crash maybe they will be
able to successfully say what the
probability of a crash is and they will
be able to successfully do so as a
function of the other measurable
economic variables right so you can
become better and better at being a
science and understanding what's going
on and giving some insight into the
future without making a precise
quantitative prediction I I don't think
that's quite Fair we shouldn't hold up
physics or even chemistry as the model
for you have to do this otherwise you're
not a science I do think that when
things are complex like they are in
economics and maybe arguably even more
in Psychology sociology
Etc it's easy to be led stray it's easy
to be led astray by what we want to be
true by our political commitments by our
personal experience rather than coldly
and calmly looking at the evidence and
judging it fairly which is what we're
supposed to do right so there's a
challenge there and maybe progress will
be slower because of that but science to
me is just looking at the world the
world that is out there and trying our
best to model it and understand it right
that's what we're doing so that's just
as true for economics as it is for
physics or astronomy
Kevin O'Toole says I loved your Berkeley
presentation on the Arrow of time in
causal networks which by the way AMA
listeners you can find on the internet
if you just Google The Arrow of time in
causal networks you can find a talk I
gave on that
then Kevin continues explaining in Broad
Strokes why the direction of perceived
causality is the same as the direction
of increasing entropy however it's
always hard to tell listening to
something like that was your
presentation teaching a well-established
consensus or advocating one possibility
in a broad ongoing discussion
good this is actually a really good
question because you're right when you
hear a talk uh on the video or when you
watch a talk on YouTube you can learn a
lot from the talk but what you don't get
is what the audience is thinking right I
mean maybe there's some q a afterward
but very often what the audience is
thinking is left unspoken in the Q a and
you know only talked about in mumbles uh
afterwards so you don't know so just
because someone says something in a talk
doesn't mean the audience agreed with it
certainly
in this case well you know also maybe
they're not telling me but I always do
try to figure out I try to ask people
like what they actually thought Etc
especially when I'm giving talks to
audiences that are different than the
ones I I usually talk to so
in this case in that you know in that
context I'm trying to bring together two
different sets of ideas one from
statistical mechanics where we talk
about entropy and the arrow time and
things like that and the other from uh
you know causal Network research and
which just assumes the directions in
which the arrows are going from causes
to effects it acts it cares a lot about
what arrows exist but it presumes we
know what directions the arrows point in
especially they always point from past
to Future so I'm trying to join together
these two things and and that audience
was extremely expert in causal Network
Dynamics causality things like that they
were not expert in um
statistical mechanics except some of
them were there were a couple of you
know stray physicists in the audience so
I think that the my impression is the
following that
um both groups were slightly annoyed at
how
easy it was to understand the part they
already knew
but they were happy to get the part they
didn't know and they they didn't have
any objections to the way that things
were brought together does that make
sense so the physicists were like why
are you telling me about the second law
of Thermodynamics I know that but when I
explained to them you know uh Judea
Pearl and causal networks they're like
wow this is really cool and the causal
Network people were just the opposite
okay so the question about whether or
not those two areas can be successfully
brought together no one seemed to be
dead set against that and they thought
that was an interesting kind of thing I
think that different people will care
more or less about it some people like
oh yeah that's really foundationally
important to understand why this comes
before that and others like come on I
don't need to know that when I inject
medicine into someone's arm and then
some physiological effect happens which
is the cause and which is the effect
right that's kind of trivial for them so
some people may or may not care but I
did not hear anyone object to the
fundamental idea or the specifically in
which specific way in which I was trying
to make it happen
Lineo miziara says in the latest AMA you
told us that boltzmann brains were not
possible because Quantum mechanically
temperature does not consist of atoms
moving around how can that be isn't the
very concept of temperature based on the
movement of atoms so by the way it's not
the boltzmann brains are not possible
it's that it is possible that they're
not possible in other words we are
expanding the universe is expanding and
accelerating and emptying out there's an
open question about the nature of the
future Quantum state of the universe
even putting aside the possibility that
will recollapse or crunch or anything
like that
the fact that the universe will be empty
and we'll have a non-zero vacuum energy
just assume all that is true what is the
nature of the quantum state in that
future accelerating universe empty space
State and there are two possibilities
um one is that it just quiets down right
it just settles into a constant static
thermal Quantum State what we call the
density Matrix or a mixed state but the
other is that it seems to do that but
really there's only a finite dimensional
hilber space that we live in only a
finite number of possible Quantum states
that the future Universe can evolve to
and eventually it will come back to
where it is today and it will recur over
and over again or there's sort of
in-between versions where it will
fluctuate even though not strictly recur
because it's an open system okay so
that's an open question we don't know
the answer to that so it is in the in
the case where the universe just settles
down once and for all then there will be
no boltzmann brains but there's
absolutely this other open possibility
where there's still will be so that I
wanted to footnote that but the
interesting question here is you know
isn't the very concept of temperature
based on the movement of atoms and the
answer is no I mean it was in the 1880s
you would have said that and everyone
would have agreed with you but
temperature was supposed to be is the
thermal uh energy the average thermal
energy of the atoms or the molecules or
whatever in your gas or your material
substance that's just not true anymore
in quantum mechanics and like physicists
always do we use the same word for a
rather different concept so in quantum
mechanics of course you can have a
circumstance where you literally have a
bunch of atoms moving around with
different velocities and then you could
attribute a temperature to it you're
just describing it quantum mechanically
that's fine but it's a special case of a
more General thing that can happen the
more General thing that can happen is
that you have a what like I said what we
call a density Matrix or a mixed state
what does that mean ordinarily in
quantum mechanics when you hear a little
bit about quantum mechanics you talk
about wave functions right the electron
one is not just a point particle with a
location it's a wave function all spread
out well you also probably have heard
that in statistical mechanics even
though we know that there really are in
well we would have known if classical
mechanics have been true that there
really were particles with definite
positions in momenta in statistical
mechanics we recognize that we don't
know the exact position of momentum of
everything and therefore we have a
probability distribution over all those
things
so you might think that in quantum
mechanics you could have a probability
distribution over wave functions right
maybe you maybe the analogy is you don't
know what the wave function of the
electrons is
and that's almost true but there's a
technical complication because wave
functions are vectors you can add them
and subtract them you can't add in and
subtract positions and momentum in uh
classical mechanics but in quantum
mechanics you can add and subtract by
the way sometimes people think that you
should be able to add positions you can
add momenta of two particles if they're
at the same point but when they're not
at the same point you can't add their
locations together you might think well
no I have a vector telling me the
location of one particle and a vector
telling me location another what stops
me from adding them the answer is you
don't have a pre-existing preferred
origin to your vector space so you it's
not actually positions of particles are
not actually vectors we treat them that
way sometimes but they're not vectors
you can sensibly add together because
that sum would depend on your origin
which is not what a good Vector space is
supposed to do anyway so that new
feature in quantum mechanics that you
can add together Quantum States means
the you can have two Quantum states that
are different from each other but only a
little bit different only like rotated
as a vector by a little bit so the way
that you describe probability
distributions over Quantum wave
functions is a little bit different than
the way you describe probability
distributions over classical
configurations
in the in the classical configuration
case like we said there's always an
answer to the question what is really
the particles positions and momenta
Quantum mechanically if you have a state
that is entangled with the rest of the
world there may not be any answer to
that and so in that case we describe the
system using a mixed state this is the
Quantum version of a statistical
distribution Over States it's kind of
like but not exactly a probability
distribution over Quantum wave functions
and you can do statistical mechanics in
that kind of framework also known as a
density Matrix I should say and so you
can say you know just like in the box of
gas at a certain temperature what is the
probability of seeing an electron to
move at a certain velocity well it's
possible but if it's very high velocity
it'll be exponentially suppressed things
like that
that translates into a certain form for
the Mixed state in quantum mechanics
that is dependent on a parameter which
we call the temperature
so the new way we think about
temperature in quantum mechanics is as a
parameter in a mixed state that tells
you the relative abundance of states of
different energies okay and you can show
that the predictions from that way of
talking map nicely onto the predictions
you would make in classical statistical
mechanics
four macroscopic things like you know
the equation of state and the PV equals
nrt things like that
but there's a huge important difference
which is that that Quantum mixed state
doesn't necessarily mean that under the
hood really deep down there's a whole
bunch of things moving around
there's a new thing that can happen in
quantum mechanics and for whatever
reason plenty of people who are super
experts in quantum mechanics don't
I don't want to say they don't
understand this maybe they understand it
they never admit it they never talk
about this fact okay the fact is you can
have a temperature you can have a mixed
state state describing a thermal
um
distribution with some temperature that
is completely static that is completely
not changing over time you can't have
that in classical mechanics and
classical mechanics whenever you talk
about a temperature just as you say in
the question you're talking about a
probability distribution over states
that are moving that are that are
individually dynamical and their average
is not moving but it's an average that
is a sum over individually moving things
that is not true anymore in quantum
mechanics in quantum mechanics a thermal
state is a sum over states that are not
moving themselves
so that's a whole new thing and people
never talk about it it's very relevant
for boltzmann Brains it's actually not
that relevant for measurements right
that's why people don't need to talk
about it because when you actually say
okay what is the probability of getting
a measurement outcome in this thermal
State you still get very similar results
in classical mechanics or quantum
mechanics but for the boltzmann brain
problem we're not thinking about
measurements we're thinking about what
happens intrinsically to the system so
suddenly that difference becomes very
very important
says is it possible that during the big
bang and its aftermath the volume or
universe is infinite but only finite
volume is contained within our past
light cone how accurately do we
understand the function volume as a
function of time after the big bang it's
100 possible in fact it's
very very possible we don't know whether
the volume of our universe is infinite
if you're a stickler there's no such
thing as the volume of our universe
because volume applies to space
and the universe is space-time right so
when you have in general relativity an
expanding Universe there are different
ways to slice space time into
three-dimensional space as a function of
time that could give you very different
answers for the question what is volume
as a function of time for example in a
very simple Universe like decider space
desitter space is an example of a
cosmological space time with a positive
vacuum energy and nothing else in it you
can slice that space time in such a way
that the volume as a function of time is
finite because it's a three-dimensional
sphere basically but it it increases
toward the future in the past without
bound so the finite volume gets infinite
but it's also possible to slice exactly
the same space time so the volume of
space is always infinite
so you can slice it one way so it is
finite one way that it's infinite that's
because it's not a well-defined thing
but our observable universe is certainly
finite okay so our observable universe
is finite we just don't know whether it
is possible to slice the universe
outside what we observe in a way that is
infinite or finite
Jeffrey Seagal or Siegel says I really
appreciated the conversation with Samuel
Bowles one point that struck me when he
mentioned that group selection could
work if the genetics of the groups was
distinct enough as he discussed this as
a possible evolutionary mechanism for
the development of racism as a
recognition of different group genetics
I don't know whether he has discussed
that or not you would have to ask him uh
of course there are genetic factors that
help Define different groups right
whether it's appearance or anything else
you I presumably you've all heard
various things about this you know the
similarities between different groups of
human beings are way greater than their
differences differences are correlated
or not correlated in different ways the
categories that we usually think of as
race do not map on straightforwardly to
any genetic differences there are
genetic differences but they don't
easily map onto how we Define things as
a function of race I think a better way
of thinking about it is uh if you go
back to the podcast we did with Nicholas
christakis human beings as part of their
basic makeup or or at least it seems
very very common in human history for
groups of people to have a slight
in-group bias we tend to Define groups
somehow and we tend to like the people
who are in a group and we don't like as
much the people who are outside our
group
when we invent races as a social
category uh we don't know anything about
genetics when we did that right we were
not very good at that so it's not
surprising that the categories that we
invent are not exactly reflective of any
underlying underlying genetic truth but
there are differences differences in
appearance differences in other things
like we said it's a social fact that we
choose to take some differences as like
really really important like what's our
skin color is and other differences like
what our hair color or eye color is less
important or you know the pitch of our
voice or whatever there's a million
differences we could have chosen to
focus on but skin color is one that we
do and that's a very social fact there
are genetic realities underlying the
differences between people but social
choices have a huge role to play here
Ryan Santos says priority question I
believe I've heard you affirm Unity of
knowledge in Prior conversations which
seems to me at a minimum that valid
methods of Discovery ought not to
contradict each other and when they do
it's a mistake of process rather than a
contradiction of reality
my question is about confrontations of
different methods in practice that lie
somewhere outside the family of Natural
Sciences for instance religious
historians will often claim that purely
academic historical methods validate
their particular scripture sometimes
contradicting the current consensus of
physics or Biology another example might
be DNA evidence used to overturn
criminal convictions would you simply
take such a situations Case by case or
is there some kind of hierarchy by which
you give one means of Investigation more
Authority than another well so I
certainly have never I'm pretty sure
have never used the words I affirm Unity
of knowledge I do think of knowledge as
different ways of talking about the same
underlying physical reality I I do
affirm the unity of underlying physical
reality and we have different mechanisms
as you say to get to it so I think that
there's actually there should be more or
less common criteria for one when those
methods are trustworthy when they are
reliable Etc of course
within a certain sphere whether you're
doing you know archeology or literary
textual analysis or particle physics the
particular problems that you are faced
with will be different compared to other
areas and therefore you can use
different criteria as a matter of
practice just for example in many
Sciences certainly in social sciences
and elsewhere people talk about a three
sigma result right you know if you can
uh get a certain p-value greater than
0.99 then you have a statistically
significant result in particle physics
we say that you need a five Sigma result
which is a much higher level of
statistical significance than in the
social sciences that's not because of
Any fundamental difference in what the
two areas are trying to to do it's a
difference in the amount of evidence
that you can gather and the cleanliness
cleanliness of the evidence that you get
in other words in particle physics you
can get five Sigma worth of evidence and
if you don't have it yet you can just
keep doing the experiment and hopefully
eventually you will get it if the effect
you're looking for or the particle
you're trying to detect is really there
in the social sciences that would mean
there were no results if you asked for
five Sigma statistical significance so
because you do want to get some results
you have a lower threshold of
significance but you also realize that
you're sort of less surprised when some
of those results are not replicated okay
in particle physics if we discovered
that you know actually we haven't found
the top Quark it's not there that would
be weird that'd be almost impossible to
make sense of because it's so firmly
established whereas there are almost no
results in sociology or psychology or
economics that are like that I think
that yeah we should um when there are
overlaps when there are questions that
can be addressed using different
methodologies probably you have to go to
on a case-by-case basis in the real
world as a practical matter but in
principle it's all just trying to figure
out how the world world works I think
that it is common I don't think that we
should certainly throw out the results
of some kinds of analysis because they
just because they disagree with a kind
of analysis we like better we should
think carefully about what is
appropriate to the question we're trying
to ask and which has been more reliable
and so forth you have to take all of it
into account at the end of the day
Steve Sheridan says in Late July a paper
was published in the astrophysical
journal by kyuhin Che from sejong
University in Seoul the paper purports
to provide strong evidence within
greater than five Sigma significance c
as we just talked about for a modified
Newtonian Dynamics gravity Theory at low
acceleration conditions of widely
separated binary Stars the Sagan
standard that extraordinary claims
require extraordinary evidence would
appear to apply here do you believe this
paper provides sufficient evidence to
support a breakdown of standard gravity
at weak accelerations and if not why no
I do not and this has something to do
with what you mean by extraordinary
evidence uh a single Paper is never
extraordinary evidence right it's only
one paper you better have some backup to
that paper to get extraordinary evidence
and when it comes to exactly this
question what's going on here is you
know in in certain theories of modified
gravity
the Newton's law of gravity is
effectively altered when the
gravitational acceleration becomes very
very low the difficulty the obvious
difficulty with testing an idea like
that is when the gravitational
acceleration is very very low
there's other forces in the world that
can get in the way okay and and suddenly
make it look like your gravitational
acceleration is something different than
it really is the gravitational
acceleration from other things than
you're looking for so people are looking
at binary stars that are very very far
apart and trying to measure their motion
around each other but guess what that's
a very hard measurement to make because
they're very far apart they're moving
slowly it's going to take them a long
time to orbit or whatever it is they're
going to do there was a paper I haven't
read the paper but there was a paper
that claimed that in some certain subset
of stars that people looked at the fit
to the data was better from modified
Newtonian Dynamics than other things but
guess what there are other papers that
look at very very similar systems and
claim that this that the fit is better
for ordinary gravity you don't hear
about those papers as much because
they're a little bit less exciting and
that's why the fact that it is nominally
a five Sigma detection does not make it
extraordinary ever evidence because
there are selection effects here which
stars did you look at how did you make
sure that you didn't have false
positives or misidentifying things
there's a whole bunch of work that needs
to be done so for huge results like this
you would know the word the world would
tell you if the scientific Community
actually thought that this had been
established we would not hide it from
you okay you would definitely hear it's
not enough to get one paper by one set
of people getting one result uh in my
career I've I've seen results appear on
the front page of the New York Times
that were completely bogus and I've even
written the paper that explained why
they were bogus so you know just be
patient when it comes to these
extraordinary claims it takes time to
really go through them part of I mean a
better quote is extraordinary claims
require careful examination of multiple
results over time by different groups
how about that
Professor beautiful says the Hubble
tension why are measurement differences
from vastly different time epochs and
inconsistency rather than just the
Hubble constant changes over time after
all inflation came and went and dark
energy is presumably changing the
expansion rate
a couple things going on here number one
the there's something called the Hubble
tension uh we did a whole episode about
it with Adam Reese a while ago he wasn't
at that time my colleague but now he is
we're both at Johns Hopkins together
um the it's not that the Hubble constant
was different that's not the tension the
tension is that there are different ways
of measuring the current Hubble constant
you can sort of do it directly but you
can also do it indirectly by measuring
features of the universe and then best
fitting to what the Hubble constant
needs to be to explain those
measurements the problem with the Hubble
tension is the different ways of
measuring the current Hubble constant
disagree with each other or more broadly
different ways of measuring cosmological
parameters are incompatible with each
other of course yes the Hubble constant
does change as a function of time the
Hubble tension is the is the fact that
it doesn't change in the right way
according to our theoretical
understanding the one little extra thing
I wanted to say is because you say dark
energy is presumably changing the
expansion rate it's actually exactly the
opposite if you had a universe with
nothing but dark energy in the form of a
cosmodial constant that is when what we
call the expansion rate would be
constant
because the expansion rate is not a
speed the expansion rate as measured by
for example the Hubble constant is
basically a time scale you know if you
think about the Hubble constant it's in
units of meters per Mia meters per
second kilometers per second per
megaparsec so that's distance divided by
time and then that whole thing is
divided by distance so the units are
just one over time we use units of
kilometers per second per megaparse
because that's convenient for our brains
but the thing we're measuring has units
of one over time it's not a velocity
it's not even an acceleration okay it's
basically the amount of time it would
take for the universe to double in size
or slightly more carefully for the
universe to exponentiate in size to an
increase by an e-fold one factor of
Euler's constant e 2.7
anyway that's the point if the universe
is constantly expanding at a fixed rate
then that is equivalent to saying the
universe is growing exponentially that's
what the acceleration of the universe
refers to if you find that confusing
it's because we're using words that we
know from our ordinary lives to discuss
velocities and accelerations when we're
really discussing the expansion of the
universe which is a different kind of
thing so anyway the expansion rate as
measured by the Hubble parameter is
decreasing with time we all know that it
is decreasing more slowly and
approaching a constant value because of
dark energy
bits plus atoms says in one of your
mystery of time lectures on the Great
Courses you say that abl or arono
Bergman and Lebovitz argue that we
perceive a Time asymmetry and wave
function collapse because we are asking
a Time asymmetric question if we pose
the question symmetrically the time
asymmetry disappears I struggle to
understand this in the many worlds
interpretation since the prepare again
phase would seem to happen after the
coherence can you help me understand
this better or at all
um probably not this is a tricky one to
understand but let me I can do a little
bit to help you get it which is that
this is not within the many worlds
interpretation really abl are really not
Advocates of the many worlds
interpretation now every experiment or
every thought experiment or real
experiment that they propose can be
understood within the many worlds
framework but that's not what they are
actually trying to do and the second
thing is there's sort of a useful part
and a less useful part in my mind of the
whole discourse around what I was
talking about in that particular lecture
this is the idea of pre-selection and
post selection for those of you who have
not I don't know if there's anyone out
there who has not listened to my
Teaching Company lectures on the mystery
of time but it's a subtlety of quantum
mechanics where the typical thing we do
is we prepare a state right so we start
and we say okay this wave function is in
a superposition of spin up and spin down
and then subsequently we measure it and
if we measure it either spin up or spin
down that's all you have so our on our
Bergman and Lego bits figured out a way
formally which is 100 fine to say well
what if you post selected after the
measurement on a Quantum State then you
could have a different formula and they
have a formula for what the
probabilities are of getting different
outcomes at the measurement in between
the question is how you in practice post
select you know the universe doesn't
give us away to post-select in a way
that we can pre-select exactly because
there's an arrow of time so in practice
what you do is you just measure again at
the end of the experiment after you've
already measured once you measure again
to try to see whether or not the state
is compatible with this post-selected
state that you want it to be in and if
it's not you throw it away you ignore
that measurement outcome and then you do
that many many many times and you can
build up statistical information about
what happens in between it's all a
hundred percent compatible with many
worlds if it were not experimentally
then I would have told you that a while
ago it's driven by a desire to have a
different way of understanding things I
don't think the world needs a different
way so I'm not I don't follow it I think
that the idea of post-selection and
related ideas of weak measurement in
quantum mechanics are very interesting I
don't think you need any of them for
understanding the foundations of quantum
mechanics
Robert Parks says in your episode with
Tim Maudlin Tim spoke of what he
considered to be an obviously erroneous
understanding of Newton's third law and
understanding is often presented as an
objection to the wave function guiding
I.E acting on particles without a
reciprocal action could you help me
understand why in quantum mechanics the
action of a wave function to particle
would not require an action of particle
to wave function well it depends what
you mean by in quantum mechanics this is
not supposed to be a claim about quantum
mechanics in general this is supposed to
be a claim about bohmian quantum
mechanics or Pilot wave theories where
you have the wave function and you also
separately have particles it is just a
fact that if you want to have a pilot
wave theory you're stuck with the real
world problem that the Schrodinger
equation works really well without any
modification so the way that they have
both the Schrodinger equation for the
wave function and some part of goals is
to say the particles are pushed to Brown
by the wave function but the wave
function is not pushed around by the
particles now two things are
simultaneously true one is that seems
weird
it seems weird to our physical intuition
to imagine that the particles are being
pushed around by the wave function but
not vice versa the second thing is but
there's no law against it okay bony
mechanics is a proposal for a different
kind of fundamental laws of physics so
it seems weird that's fine you're 100
willing to say it seems weird to me I
don't like it you're not allowed to say
therefore it's wrong therefore it can't
be right it's a theory it's a proposal
for a physical theory that you can think
about and you can you know decide
whether or not it fits the data and so
forth and so on but it's not supposed to
be compatible with some very naive
formulation of Newton's third law to
every action there's an equal and
opposite reaction
tease Johnson says wimps are a very
probable candidate for dark matter where
the m stands for massive massive
particles decaying the lighter particles
unless there's a conserved property and
conserved properties are linked to
symmetries so if a massive Dark Matter
particle doesn't Decay there should be
at least a symmetry to discover maybe
even a new Force I don't hear anyone
talking about this in Popular Science
media like magazines or YouTube even
though quantum mechanics is a Hot Topic
to discuss or sorry even though dark
matter is a Quantum is a Hot Topic to
discuss DM rather than qm what am I
missing here
um you're not missing anything they're
just it's just not a popular topic to
discuss we don't know a lot about dark
matter we know a lot about its
phenomological astrophysical properties
but we don't know a lot about its
astrophysical problem it's darn it we
don't know a lot about its particle
physics properties so you're right wimps
are a probable candidate in the sense
that they're a popular candidate I
should say there's probably a better way
of saying it wimps are supposed to be
heavy heavier than a proton typically so
they could very easily decay in fact one
context in which wimp models are often
studied are supersymmetric models and if
you just wrote down a supersymmetric
model without trying too hard you would
get a wimp-like particle but it would
Decay away pretty quickly way too
quickly to be the dark matter so there
is a subset of all the possible
supersymmetric models you can write down
which have a new symmetry called R
symmetry or R parity capital r the
letter and that's basically you know
something that you just put on your
theory and it prevents the lightest
super partner whatever that might be
from decaying because that is a new
symmetry but it doesn't give rise to a
force because actually in the simplest
versions it's just a discrete symmetry
it's not a gauge symmetry that would
give rise to a new force of nature so
once you've said it's there there's not
a lot more to say about it
of course it's also possible to imagine
that the thing that stabilizes the dark
matter is a gauge Symmetry and then
there would be a new force in fact I
wrote a paper about that with Matt
Buckley Lottie Ackerman and Mark
kaminkowski about dark electromagnetism
so U1 gauge symmetry that stabilizes the
Dark Matter particle so you can talk
about that but it's you know one of
those things where it's possible but
it's really an extra complication on top
of dark matter and we haven't discovered
it yet so even I who wrote the paper
would not get too excited about it until
we had more reason to think it was on
the right track
the Shannon Clyde asks a priority
question I remember I've already said
this but we've already had a priority
question but remember that
priority questions are those that every
patreon supporter gets to ask once in
their life and I will make a good faith
effort to answer it so we get too many
questions overall for me to answer all
of them but priority questions I will
try to answer I cannot guarantee
satisfactory answer or satisfying one
but I'll do my best
in your July 17 podcast discussion you
and Dr Joe silk agreed that Cosmic
inflation has about a 50 chance of being
right are there any alternative big bang
speculations that populate the other 50
I.E hot big bang theories without Alan
guth's Cosmic inflation
oh there are uh there absolutely are the
most popular ones are bouncing or cyclic
cosmologies but none of the others are
anywhere near 50 let's put it that way
in in my own personal accounting if
inflation is 50 something that we
haven't yet thought of is probably 48
percent
or you know comparable to inflation
anyway I don't think that any of the
Alternatives that I've seen to inflation
are themselves anywhere near as
compelling as inflation is so but
there's plenty of phase space out there
for theories we just haven't thought of
yet so you have to give some Credence to
those as well
Sean Bentley says my son jack was
wondering if you've heard or of or read
the three body problem series by Sinjin
Liu we both really enjoyed it especially
from a Layman physics perspective also
curious if you have any thoughts on the
book's namesake the actual three-body
problem in physics so I do know about
the book I've I'm very sad to say I've
started to read it but I haven't
finished it not because I didn't like it
just because other things in life get in
the way sometimes so I can't comment on
the book itself it's a great title the
three body problem because the three
body problem refers to the question in
Newtonian gravity of three objects
orbiting each other and it's a
fascinating problem because of course
the two body problem two bodies orbiting
each other uh that's perfectly solvable
Newton solved it back in the day and the
three body problem which you would think
might not be that much harder is
completely unsolvable at least you
cannot Solve IT analytically in terms of
a closed form expression you can put on
a computer and simulate it but it turns
out to be chaotic as we later realize
probably Punker a was one of the first
people to realize this so it's an
example of let's be very clear about
what chaos theory here means it's still
deterministic it's still laplace's demon
has no trouble predicting it if you know
exactly what the system is going is
doing right now you can predict exactly
what it will do next
the difference is what happens when you
admit that you don't know exactly what
the system is doing now in a non-chaotic
system a small amount of ignorance now
leads to a small deviation in your
predictions about the future in a
chaotic system a small amount of
ignorance now leads to potentially large
deviations about your predictions in the
future essentially because we always do
in the real world have some small amount
of ignorance some small amount of
uncertainty you cannot very carefully
very exactly very precisely predict
what's going to happen next and that's
true in the three body problem think
about it this way
in some regime if you have three bodies
and they're orbiting each other the two
bodies there might be two bodies that
are very close and orbiting each other
nearby and a third body that is far away
so for some intents and purposes that
third body just orbits the center of
mass of the other two so it looks like
you can figure it out but there's little
perturbations those perturbations grow
and when the three bodies are zooming
right next to each other one of the
three is typically just kicked out of
the system entirely
and predicting exactly when that might
happen is very very hard so it's a
wonderful little metaphor for chaos
theory in general and a reminder how
easy it is for a very simple dynamical
system to exhibit that kind of
unpredictability
Nikita loves a loser boy sorry uh says
while participating in my first
meditation course recently a teacher
hinted at a rather rather radical idea
that could be shortly shortly quoted as
maybe we don't have a body at all
accepting that our bodies are nothing
then
I'm sorry I have trouble reading this
it's not your fault Nikita it's
completely my fault accepting that our
bodies are nothing more than just an
exquisitely arranged array of particles
and interactions between them would you
be willing to agree that the entire my
body concept is indeed an emergent
phenomenon
it's 100 an emerging phenomenon yes that
is true everything's an emerging
phenomenon that does not appear in the
most fundamental laws of physics okay
now we don't even know the most
fundamental laws of physics but our
current version of the most fundamental
laws of physics is the core theory of
the standard model of particle physics
plus general relativity and you can look
at that all day long if you want and you
will never locate a body in there
everything macroscopic everything
Collective everything constituted from
many different little bits that are
individually mentioned in the core
Theory would be an emerging phenomenon
in human bodies or other large systems
absolutely qualify now that doesn't mean
you don't have a body it's a silly to
say that you don't have a body in my
personal opinion just because something
is emerging doesn't mean it's not real
if you if if you had that attitude then
you would literally not know anything
that was real because like I said you
don't know the fundamental laws of
physics right now our best theory is the
core Theory but it's possible things
like electrons and quarks are also
emerge entire level phenomena we don't
know
so if you have this strict construal of
reality where unless it's fundamental
it's not real then you don't think that
anything is real as far as you know and
that's no way of go to go through life
in my opinion
Mark Smith asks how did you pick the
title and ending music for mindscape
uh that's a pretty easy question
actually I didn't want to bother getting
permission I didn't want to pay for any
music so I have a friend in former
collaborator from my grad school days
Ted Pine he and I wrote a couple papers
together on topological defects and on
microwave background and isotropies and
after graduate school he formed a band
called euphonic I think you could
probably find them on the internet if
you dug around and they had a few CDs
and I asked Chad if I could use some of
their music for the intro and outgoing
outro music for mindscape and he said
yes so all this is more or less
explained there is if you go to the
website preposterousuniverse.com podcast
you can click on about mindscape and it
will actually mention all these things
Diana David Roos says always I've been
puzzled by the concept of inertia in
Newtonian mechanics inertia is the
tendency of an object to remain at rest
if it's at rest or to remain moving at a
constant velocity if it's in motion
unless acted on by an external force
from the perspective of Einstein's
theory relativity objects with mass will
prefer to move along straight lines in
the curved space time when we try to
divert an object from the straight line
path we're effectively trying to make it
deviate from its natural motion however
still in my mind the question of why
objects have inertial property I.E this
tendency of following the geodesics
remains is there something more
fundamental that I don't understand
I don't think there is something more
fundamental that you don't understand
other than
when you are and are not allowed to ask
questions about why something is true
right
um in a mathematical context if you want
to say why are straight lines the
shortest distance paths in euclidean
Geometry or why are geodesics shortest
distance pads and non-euclidean geometry
you can answer that in terms of other
mathematical Concepts but when you're
asking about the physical behavior of
things sometimes the answer is that's
just the way it is
I could quote other laws of physics from
which you can derive the fact that test
particles move on inertial paths in
general relativity but then you could
ask well why are those laws of physics
true so I'm not sure what use it is to
quote those other laws of physics in my
mind it's a law of physics that's how
nature behaves our job is to discover it
it might be there's some deeper Theory
from which it's derived and that would
be great but right now when it comes to
classical gravity general relativity is
the deepest theory that we have so we
accept it until something better comes
along
Walter E Miller says I really enjoyed
your conversation with Avi Loeb a while
back and I found his speculations about
umamuma quite interesting
he has come under a lot of criticism
lately in the scientific Community but
that is not dampened his enthusiasm for
his opinions what do you think about his
recent Vines of spherical metallic
particles scraped from the bottom of the
ocean that might be of extrasolar origin
you know I thought when I did the
conversation with Avi who I've known for
a very long time
um that we had a very good reasonable
conversation Uma is this
object that zoomed into the solar system
and zoomed Away by Zoom I mean just
traveled and it wasn't under rocket
power or anything like that but there
was some anomalous acceleration of the
object which is something that makes
perfect sense because when objects pass
close by the sun pockets of ice and
things like that often outgass and push
the object off of its trajectory so
that's not surprising but Avi made the
case that we should at least contemplate
the possibility this is an artificial
object an Interstellar spaceship okay I
think that's extremely unlikely I think
that his case was unconvincing but I
think it's perfectly reasonable thing to
contemplate and you should certainly
take the possibility seriously just
because it's kind of kind of wacky and
out there doesn't mean we shouldn't
think about it the implications would be
really big if it were were important so
I was happy to have the conversation
I do think that since then he has not
been a careful scientist about this
question he has you know written papers
and continued to push the idea that we
should take very seriously the existence
of artifacts pointing toward
extraterrestrial intelligent origin and
a recent example are these little
metallic particles scrape from the
bottom of the ocean nothing that I've
seen from the perspective of other
scientists who are experts in this area
think that he's on the right track about
this and it's pretty Universal dismissal
of these claims and he seemed to be
rushing into print and just not being
careful and things like that so
you know he's still a good scientist
he's still writing papers and and
sending them to referee journals so
we'll see how things go forward but
again as we said with the mon stuff
previously what you want to take any of
this seriously is multiple different
sets of people reaching the same
conclusion ideally from different
perspectives but at least multiple
people you know who might want to
disagree with each other ending up
having to agree with each other because
the data forced them to we're nowhere
near that yet so again I would just not
think that there's much reason to get
excited about this
Nate whatups says has the rise of
generative language models like chat GPT
LED you to change the way you come up
with tests or homework or the way that
you evaluate your students test results
or homework results so so far not yet
but maybe that has to do with how I do
things or maybe it has to do with the
current state of uh AI you know in the
in the courses that I tend to teach I'm
either teaching a seminar kind of course
where the grading is papers rather than
homework or in-class exams I actually
kind of hate in-class exams I'm not sure
if I've ever given an in-class exam in
my many years of being a professor I
give problem sets and and take home
finals in uh more mathie physics e
courses and I ask students to write
papers and grade on the on the
performance on those papers and in class
participation in the more seminar
Humanity kinds of classes so
I I'm not right now teaching a physics
mathie based class so I don't have to
worry about students answering those
questions using chat GPT I'm not sure if
I would like if you're supposed to do a
certain physics problem and you can do
it using AI
maybe that's just fine as long as AI is
going to be around for a long time for
the papers
um that's an issue and I am confronting
this issue and I you know it was
interesting I I'm teaching two classes
this semester and I asked my students in
both class both classes and you know
they uh maybe they're fibbing or not
completely telling the truth but they
were very against the idea of using AI
they're like Ah that's just cheating is
this going to be BS I don't think we
should believe that stuff so we're not
going to do that now again maybe that
they're um Whistling Dixie or whatever
but they didn't seem like oh no I'm sad
that I don't get to use AI what I told
them was they can use it but number one
they certainly can't use it to literally
write their papers or even parts of
their papers I don't want any cut and
pasting from AI into papers and number
two if they do use it they need to be
explicit it's a source that they're
using so they need to credit it they
need to say I use the chat GPT for this
purpose you know to point to some issues
or to formulate a sentence or to find
some references or whatever it is
because I don't think that you can just
say don't use it when it's a tool that's
out there in the real world you're not
doing your students the best possible
service from pretending that something
is not possible when it really is and of
course I also think that the class
participation is an important part of
the grade also so so far the short
answer is it hasn't greatly affected my
grading or assignment giving but we'll
see it maybe it will in the future
astronomel says when I decide not to put
cream in my coffee do I postpone the
thermal equilibrium death of the
universe by a tiny bit
the way that you've stated the question
I don't know what the answer is because
you have the the point is that if you
put cream in the cough you increase the
entropy of the universe a little bit
that's true it was a joke by John
Wheeler that he felt guilty every time
he put cream in a coffee because he was
increasing the entropy of the universe
and there's no going back okay but that
doesn't strictly speaking mean that you
are in making it faster the approach to
equilibrium because you know if the sun
blows up or you know expands to a red
giant and engulfs the Earth then it
doesn't matter whether you put your
cream in your coffee or not it's going
to be that event that increases the
entropy of everything on Earth okay of
course it's all just a joke because the
amount by which you arguably might be
increasing entry of the universe is
completely negligible compared to the
whole entropy of the universe so I
wouldn't sweat it in Practical terms
Pablo Montilla says we know black holes
should evaporate due to Hawking
radiation that being the case is there
any point during evaporation when the
mass of the black hole is low enough so
that light can escape thus ceasing to be
a black hole so no there is no such
point the black hole just grows smaller
remember a black hole is a region of
space a region of space time really it's
a region of space-time from which light
cannot Escape okay there is a tricky
technical question about how to think
about that when there is such a thing as
Hawking radiation because of the
following if you if you imagine throwing
something into the black hole let's
imagine it's a a kind of abstract thing
so it's not like a book or a rocket ship
but it's a bit of information
given that the black hole eventually
evaporates away that bit of information
will eventually escape to the outside
world okay so you could in some very
strict construal kind of sense argue
that when there is hawking radiation
there are antenne black holes Hawking
himself said something along these lines
but the rest of the world is gonna you
know shrug and go come on you know what
we mean you can't escape right then you
have to wait until the black hole
evaporates to escape that's not really
what we have in mind
but anyway the black hole is a region of
space-time from which light cannot
escape and that region grows smaller as
the black hole grows smaller uh loses
mass and eventually it will reach zero
and there's no black hole left anymore
but there's no point at which the Event
Horizon disappears it just shrinks to
zero size
Paul Conte says in the matter of AI and
Common Sense would it at least help an
AI to learn if there were a pair of if
it were given a pair of stereo cameras
and stereo microphones and a pair of
movable prosthetic arms and sensitive
articulated hands with such a peripheral
attachment the AI could see here and
learn about different shape sizes and
even about basic gravity although this
would not actually lead to Common Sense
it would surely be a great Improvement
toward that goal you know I'm not an
expert but my impression is that yes
this is exactly true people who do
robotics have found that ai's this is
old news so maybe it's different now in
the large language model era but my
impression is that embodied AIS begin to
act more human than AIS that just talk
to you through the computer screen
um they you know have a set of gestures
that can interact with other people and
they can see their gestures Etc so I
would not be surprised if that were
completely true there's another thing
that is missing in modern large language
models which I think is even more
important which is feelings in the sense
that Antonio dimacio and I talked about
on the podcast so not in the sense of
like oh you hurt my feelings but in the
sense that we are our bodies and our
minds are constantly trying to maintain
homeostasis right there's some
form of equilibrium in which we're happy
and content and we are constantly
departing from that form because we're
too hot or we're hungry or we're tired
or whatever and we work to restore it
and this provides the motivation for us
to do many things in life and none of
this exists for current AI models so I I
do think that if you actually wanted an
AI model that would approach something
like human intelligence or Consciousness
you would both have to embody or not
maybe have to but it would help your
case greatly both to embody it and to
give it some feelings to give it some
desires some goals that it could fall
short of and it would try to fix itself
you know current language model doesn't
get bored if you don't talk to it you
need them to get bored before they will
be become conscious
I'm going to group two questions
together Sheldon Silliman says I was
wondering if you ever had entertained
the idea of writing science fiction the
scientific accuracy of books like the
Martian seem to help present scientists
and engineers in a more positive light
we could use more books without
attention to Scientific detail
and uh some random crackpot that is
their given name I did not invent that
one some random crackpot says I enjoyed
the Alice and Robert chapter in
something deeply hidden I was wondering
if you've ever enjoyed writing fiction
or if you'd think about enjoying doing
so at some point a Sci-Fi story from you
would certainly Rock
I've absolutely thought about writing
fiction
um the specific idea of trying to write
a science fiction tale that would be
distinguished by being especially
accurate or especially inspiring to a
new generation of potential scientists
is not actually my biggest motivation
here if I did write a fiction the two
kinds of things that intrigue me look I
have no time to do this right now so
we're talking call me back 10 years from
now to see if I've done this this is not
something that is imminent in any way
but I could imagine doing either
a mystery novel I love mystery novels as
we talked about in the comfort food
discussion before and that would just be
something to be completely different in
my brain which would always be fun or I
could imagine you know writing a an
intellectual book in the form of a kind
of dialogue in a sort of fictional
fictional scenario like the Alice and
Bob chapter in something deeply hidden
where there were character is talking
about ideas but they were doing so in
kind of a narrative way I do I feel
slightly bad that all the trade books
I've ever written are a little bit hard
are a little bit high level uh I mean
there's differences the biggest ideas in
the universe books are higher level than
the previous ones but all my books are a
little bit demanding you know compared
to other people's books there's no books
that I would that I would give that I've
written to someone who Not only was not
an expert in science but actively didn't
like it for example I would love to
write a science book that would be
enjoyed by people who actively don't
like science and maybe a narrative
structure would be a good way to do that
again no imminent plans along those
lines but you know who knows life is
short got a lot of things I've got to do
Anonymous says I know you said that
human needs are changing Over time
however the human need for shelter has
been pretty stable for a while would it
be possible to get the amount of time
every individual needs to spend to
obtain shelter for themselves to go down
exponentially it actually seems to be
going up globally with all of our
automation what is going wrong with
automated Utopia in this domain
so I'm not sure uh what to say about
this I debated whether to answer it
because I don't think that my answer is
going to be very enlightening here as I
said earlier I do think that as a
species we have enough resources right
now to give every human being shelter
we're making choices to have a kind of
society where some people are
unsheltered and that's just something
that we're all responsible for right
something that we all have to take that
responsibility for making that choice
when we could make another one I don't
know the numbers I'm not at all sure
that it's true that it takes more and
more time for each individual to obtain
shelter or anything like that these
questions are very very hard to answer
because the human race is very
heterogeneous right
people who are sort of of my age in my
income bracket are spending a lot more
money on housing than they were when I
was born okay so housing prices have
gone way up uh there's enormous number
of complicated factors that go into that
that I'm not an expert on talking about
so short answer is I don't know why this
is true I do think that we could make it
very different we're choosing not to it
is something we should at least
recognize as a as a fact about the world
that could be a different way if we
wanted it to be
Robert ruxandrescue asks we say that in
the MWI the many world's interpretation
once decoherence happens the branches
can't communicate with each other or at
least that the probability is very very
small but not zero what would happen to
a conscious experience if two separate
branches with two copies of the Observer
seeing an electron in position a and
position B would unify back into a
single one would that person remember
being in a superposition having
experienced both the electron in
position a and the electron in position
B
this is an interesting question but I
think I'm going to give a not completely
satisfying answer to it because I think
that it's not quite a well-posed
question as it is I mean I know what you
mean we have the situation in many
worlds where when you make a measurement
what does that mean to make a
measurement it really means that some
quantum mechanical system that was in a
superposition by our lights has become
entangled with this environment that's
the coherence and the whole point is
that if the environment is Big right so
entanglement with the environment means
not only does the particular thing that
you've measured gone out of
superposition but it's affected by
becoming entangled with many many other
degrees of freedom in the environment so
the idea of branches coming back
together is by itself not a well-defined
one what do you mean by coming back
together are you undoing all that
entanglement with the environment are
you changing all of those Impressions if
I measure the position of an electron
and I see that it's in position a not
position B then that memory that fact
distributes through my brain right it's
not just like one bit that I can access
there's various parts of my brain that
are aware that the electron was in
position a so I don't know what it means
to sort of re-go back to a unified
Branch anymore and this is reflecting
reflective of the fact that it's one of
those questions where it makes perfect
sense to form the question but there are
assumptions underneath that don't quite
hang together things like having a
memory of something only happen because
of the arrow of time right because of
increasing entropy and the fact that
there are facts about the current state
of the universe which in a world of
increasing entropy imply something about
the past when you see a footprint on a
beach you imply the existence of a foot
that was there not too long long ago in
the space of all possible ways that
Footprints can appear on beaches most of
them have nothing to do with feet but
when you conditionalize on being in a
very very low entropy past then it
becomes overwhelmingly likely that a
foot caused that footprint
so if you are Imagining the two branches
come back together that is a fluctuation
that decreases the entropy of the
universe you have temporarily ignored
the arrow of time and pushed things back
into alignment anyway it's like
unseparating or separating unmixing
cream and coffee once again so what that
means is that the whole idea of having a
memory is no longer quite valid because
you've undone some of the things that go
into what it means to make a memory
anyway so I just don't think that I
think that it is certainly possible
mathematically to take two branches of
the wave function and to put them back
into some kind of superposition but you
have to be much more specific well
number one it's not going to happen as a
realistic fact but number two even as a
thought experiment you have to just be a
lot more explicit about what some of the
details are here
Chris K asks a priority question I agree
with you the Consciousness is emergent
and deterministically bound to the
physics of the brain but I struggle to
understand how it isn't simultaneously a
thing that exists and also a thing that
is non-physical is it your belief that
my thoughts and conscious experience are
themselves made of waves particles in
the same way a rock is and that the
thought in my mind has a location in the
physical universe that can be pinpointed
well I do think that Consciousness is
emergent uh whether it's non-physical
it's going to depend on exactly how you
parse that so I'm not going to make too
much of that it is similar to the way a
rock is a physical thing it's made of
waves particles but when we have these
higher level vocabularies we use
Concepts that are much more flexible and
Abstract than simply referring to a
physical object right if I say the
Star-Spangled Banner the national anthem
of the United States does that exist
yeah I'm pretty sure that exists I've
heard it I've sung it badly in in the
past does it have a physical location
the Star-Spangled Banner no it's kind of
an idea right it's it's manifested
whenever you sing it or you're at the
beginning of the baseball game or what
have you likewise there's plenty of
higher level Concepts that play a useful
role in our understanding of the world
that have causal power that have
implications when we talk about them Etc
but aren't embodied in some physical
location cause and effect relationships
are an obvious example so you don't need
to imagine that Consciousness is located
at a point in order to imagine that it's
a physical real thing that emerges at a
higher level description those are
perfectly compatible things
Dave grundgeiger also asks an emergence
question the macro world is emergent and
the result of coarse graining what do
you think is the likelihood that there
exist multiple orthogonal core
screenings that are individually
consistent useful and result in complex
worlds that are undetected by each other
I would love to know the answer to this
at a detailed level but my guess my
belief is that the likelihood is very
very small I know what you mean so
basically what we're doing here is
saying let's just keep it very simple
let's just keep it classical and we're
looking around and we have the world
with a bunch of atoms and I'm coarse
graining it into things like tables and
chairs and computers and stuff like that
so basically what I'm doing is I'm
grouping together whole bunches of atoms
and calling them an object so the
question is are there different
groupings you know rather than this
table right in front of me that has some
physical coherent location in space I
can talk about this atom in the table
and that atom over in the other room as
part of a different higher level course
grain thing
the problem with that is that that thing
I invented that coarse grain object that
involves some atoms in the table some
atoms in the atmosphere in another room
somewhere that doesn't help understand
the world in any way there's no simple
pattern that is obeyed by that
particular coarse grained structure it
doesn't have any causal efficacy in the
world the table if I just say I have a
table in front of me if I tell you right
now that I'm speaking into a microphone
that is on a table looking at a computer
with various questions on them that is
also sitting on the table you kind of
know what's going on right I'm actually
giving you useful information and the
reason why in the real actual World in
which we live that certain things make
more physical sense to coarse grain than
others is mostly due to spatial locality
right I mean we've coarse grained in a
way that the table has a location I can
tell you where it is and that makes
sense to you in some immediate way and
in bank that has solidity right if I
touch the table in one end then it's
going to affect the table somewhere else
all of these down-to-earth physical
properties make this the right core
screening to use is it possible there's
some very different core screening yes I
mean you might even guess that in
quantum gravity ads CFT is an example of
a weird different coarse graining adsc
of T is this Duality that you get in
string theory between a let's say an
n-dimensional quantum gravity Theory
with anti-decider boundary conditions
and an N minus one dimensional theory on
the boundary with no gravity at all but
interestingly people who have thought
about adsc of D so the two theories are
supposed to be the same even though
they're in different numbers of
dimensions that's obviously going to be
some wildly non-local map between them
but people don't really think about core
screening on either side you know does
it make sense to coarse grain does it
make sense to have physical objects on
both sides because there's like strong
coupling on one side weak coupling on
the other side this is a great question
that I think philosophers should think
about more philosophers of physics but
they don't because I am not the boss of
the world and I do not get to assign
homework problems to everyone within
Academia but if I could that's one that
I would definitely assign
Paul Hess says in an answer during your
August AMA he described a photon with a
spherical wave function and you implied
that it's pretty typical to be emitted
that way I had previously conceptualized
a wave function to be much more
directional usually with a large moving
Peak where the particle is most likely
to be found can you clarify whether a
spherical Photon wave function is a
special case if it's not spherical is
this concept specific to photons or many
types of particles
it's actually the generic case you get
some kind of spherical-ish wave function
when you emit a particle if you have a
particle that is trapped somewhere right
a particle that is an electron within an
atom then its wave function is going to
have a definite shape but we're thinking
here of particles that have been emitted
either in radioactive decay or a photon
or whatever how do photons get emitted
you have an electron and it gets shaken
somehow right you move the electron
around up and down very quickly and that
emits a photon but that up and down
moving doesn't because it's going both
up and down it doesn't pick out a
direction in space if you have a laser
or something like that that's very
different lasers will pick out
directions in space even if you have a
flashlight it's not intrinsically
emitting light in a direction you know
you got to sort of focus it there with
either mirrors or or lenses or something
like that the generic thing for light to
do is to spread out in a spherical wave
that's true through classically and it
just remains true Quantum mechanically
classically you probably think you can
visualize that pretty simply if you just
think about light waves Quantum
mechanically you tend not to visualize
that because eventually you're going to
see the particle and you're not going to
see the whole wave right that's the
difference between classical mechanics
and quantum mechanics so you can for
example as we did talk about in the
August AMA you can track you can look at
a track of a particle at the detector
the LHC or in a bubble chamber or
whatever and it looks like that particle
has a point-like trajectory but that's
because you're measuring it before you
measured it that particles wave function
was spreading out in something like a
spherical wave not exactly spherical the
details will matter but they will tend
to spread out another in all directions
until they are actually measured
somewhere
George asks my question concerns the
heat death of the universe and I was
recently speaking with a friend of mine
who received his bachelor's in physics a
few years ago he said he was talking
with his professors already I'm
skeptical because there's like many
chains here in the communication but the
professor was talking about how a new
universe might be able to be created
after the heat death of our universe
you know it's possible I've written
papers about it the paper I wrote was
Jennifer Chen on the Arrow of time and
spontaneous inflation is an example of
uh baby universes being created in the
far future but look we don't know we
don't not only do we not know in a sort
of strict sense that we haven't observed
it but we have no very solid theories
about this we have we're not completely
clueless we have some ideas that we push
around you know it's it's important to
know when we talk about we don't
understand quantum gravity that's true
but we understand a lot about quantum
mechanics and we understand a lot about
gravity so it's not like anything goes
when it comes to quantum gravity uh
there's still some things that are more
reasonable more likely than others and
it's absolutely possible to contemplate
scenarios in which something happens in
the far future of the universe that
brings the universe back to life either
in some large region or in some tiny
little baby Universe type of region but
honestly we we don't know we don't
understand the physics well enough to
say one way or the other so it's fun to
think about interesting to think about
but don't rely on it for anything for
any planning purposes I don't know
Jeff B says when we say that a region of
space has a finite number of degrees of
freedom is this equivalent to saying
that reality is fundamentally discrete
or is there a more subtle relationship
it's a little bit more subtle
relationship you know again this is
quantum mechanics we're talking about
it's not classical mechanics quantum
mechanics in its basic formulation with
the Schrodinger equation Etc is not
discrete okay it is just wrong to think
that the fact that the world is quantum
somehow implies some discreetness to it
I I ramble on about this in the upcoming
book the upcoming Volume 2 of biggest
ideas in the universe on quanta and
Fields because in something like an atom
where you have discrete energy levels
for the electron that's not because the
laws of physics are discrete the laws of
physics are smooth it's a wave equation
the Schrodinger equation is that the set
of solutions to that equation in that
particular setup is discrete so quantum
mechanics itself if you just do regular
quantum mechanics nature is not discrete
full stop I recently wrote a paper
um very recently pointing out that in
certain special cases if things line up
just right you can take quantum
mechanics and you can discretize it you
can discretize the evolution of the wave
function in Hilbert's space so that it
is truly discrete there are some
cosmological issues that come up there
but otherwise it's fairly plausible that
that could be the real world but we have
no reason to think it's the real world
it was just sort of intellectual in
exercise in pointing out this is a
possibility that we can consider but
anyway I think that's not what you're
getting at when you ask about the
fundamental degrees of freedom the
finite number of degrees of freedom
usually in quantum mechanics what we
mean by that is the dimensionality of
Hilbert space Hilbert space is the space
of all Quantum wave functions right for
any point particle moving in space or
any Quantum Fields the dimensionality
filter space is infinite so it is not
discrete but if you have just a spin a
single qubit that's just a 2 dimensional
hilber space that's finite and there are
good reasons from quantum gravity and
black hole entropy and the beckenstein
bound and words like that to think that
the physical number of degrees of
freedom in the sense of the
dimensionality of Hilbert's space is
finite within any finite-sized region of
space
but again that doesn't mean that nature
is discrete in the regular sense because
it is a vector the the thing that we're
just using to describe the universe is a
vector in a finite dimensional Vector
space but the vector is still continuous
it still moves continuously through that
Vector space right so that in that sense
in those senses there is a more subtle
relationship there
Kyle Stevens says with the continued
proliferation of seemingly existential
threats to humanity such as pandemics
unaligned AI nuclear war climate change
I can't help but feel that the
philosophical doomsday argument
continues to gain more Credence with
each passing day given these existential
threats should we lend any additional
Credence to the possibility the Doomsday
argument accurately accounts for why we
find ourselves to exist so early in the
universe so for those who don't know the
Doomsday argument uh is one of these
arguments that is based on the
assumption that we are somehow typical
observers within some class some
reference class of observers so if that
reference class of observers is all
human beings who ever live okay well
then in that case uh it is very very
unlikely that we are within
chronologically the first one percent of
human beings who ever live right because
that would be only a one percent chance
so therefore you suddenly have a
prediction for how many human beings
could possibly live or at least probably
live into the future not so many I mean
maybe a few more Generations but pretty
soon you're going to hit that 99 Mark
and it's going to become unlikely so I
think this is just a mistake like just
obviously wrong this argument because we
are not typical observers we're going to
talk about this again later in the AMA
but I've mentioned this before I talked
about it a little bit of length in the
solo podcast from a while ago on the
philosophy of cosmology someday I'm
going to write a paper about this
because I think everyone gets this wrong
to be honest so I just have zero uh
Credence in the Doomsday argument just
to point out one obvious reason not to
believe it why did you say all human
beings ever existing rather than all
life forms ever existing right you'd get
very different answers if you said that
but you have to pick a reference class
you pick it arbitrarily and your answer
depends very very sensitively on that
choice when the answer to a purported
objective question depends sensitively
on a completely random and arbitrary
choice you are probably making a mistake
I would say and I think in the Doomsday
argument that's very clear but you are
correctly Kyle pointing out the fact
that there is something new about
Humanity in recent Generations namely
that we in a way that we didn't a
hundred or a thousand years ago have the
capacity to really do disastrous things
to life on Earth including all of human
beings right so in that sense the
chances that we do something terrible
that destroys life on Earth or destroys
all human life is much bigger now than
it used to be I that's a perfectly
reasonable argument but that didn't make
any assumptions about typicality or
anything like that that just said
through technology we have a lot more
leverage over ending lives here on Earth
than we ever did that's the route I
would go down if I wanted to think about
this kind of philosophical argument
Jared Sage says is it on the table the
Dark Matter isn't a fundamental particle
against the standard model but instead
is some quasi-particle that's an
excitation in an abstract
non-fundamental field
sure it's on the table many things are
on the table I don't think it's on the
table that it's a quasi-particle in
standard model Fields I do think that
you need some degrees of freedom beyond
the standard model to do it with the
obvious exception that it could be tiny
black holes or medium-sized black holes
for that matter a black hole in some
very real sense is a quasi-particle
right it's a extended excitation of
existing Fields like the gravitational
fields in the matter fields and so forth
but that's probably not what you have in
mind I think that you would need other
fields I don't think the fields we know
about in the standard model are up to
the task of giving you some unknown
quasi-particle excitations that could be
the Dark Matter especially because
standard model Fields tend to interact
not be dark they would uh most ways I
could think of to make bound states of
standard model particles would interact
electromagnetically like hydrogen atoms
interact electronic magnetically even
though they're themselves electrically
neutral because they're made of
electrically charged constituents right
so I think that this kind of thing is in
the realm of you're welcome to think
about it but we have no great reason to
suspect that it's on the right track and
it'll be hard to constrain your own
theorizing
Tomer hakonen says uh hakkohan sorry
hakkahen says what is the relationship
between the notion of time and general
relativity and the thermodynamic Arrow
of time for my limit understanding of gr
the main difference between time and the
other coordinates of space times that
the sign of the metric is negative for
the zero zero index can one in principle
start from the signature of the metric
is minus plus plus and derive the zeroth
coordinate is the one along which
entropy grows uh no well because
yes in general relativity or in special
relativity or for that matter in
Newtonian mechanics there is a
difference between space and time and
that difference is reflected in the
relativity versions in the fact that the
metric has a different sign in the
timeline Direction than the space-like
directions none of that has anything to
do with entropy okay you can imagine a
box of gas that is in thermal
equilibrium and the entropy is neither
growing nor shrinking but time is still
passing because all the molecules in the
gas are still moving right the arrow of
time is over and above the existence of
time itself that minus sign in the
metric says there is something called
time there's a coordinate that is
different than space it does not say
that there's any arrow pointing along
that direction which you know because
there's no arrow pointing in the spatial
directions right there can be in fact
there is here on Earth there's an arrow
pointing toward the center of the earth
called where gravity is pulling you to
board we don't make a big deal about
that Arrow because its explanation is
perfectly obvious there's the Earth
beneath our feet pulling us down we know
it's not there in the fundamental laws
of physics and we know it's not out
there in outer space far away from the
earth right the arrow of time is only
different because it's everywhere and it
starts at the Big Bang we don't know
exactly why that happened but it is like
The Arrow of space here on Earth it is
something that is not ingrained in the
nature of space-time itself it's a
feature of our local environment
Moshe fader says what are your three
favorite cocktails and why would you
consider developing a signature
mindscape cocktail for the drinking
pleasure of your patreon fans
well that's a good idea although I'll
have to confess my ability to create new
cocktails is pretty limited I've tried
I've done it sometimes more successful
than others let's just put it that way
um so I'll take suggestions uh within
patreon for what could be the best
mindscape cocktail or mindscape cocktail
list for that matter you know Jennifer
did for a long time have a Blog called
cocktail party physics where she
collected physics cocktails in the
sidebar but they were all pretty
horrible you didn't want to wouldn't
want to drink these things they were
either just regular cocktails with
physicsy names or uh terrible
concoctions that were meant to reflect
some physical principles that would not
ever be served in a bar let's put it
that way I'm much more standard in fact
I'm kind of boring when it comes to
cocktails you know I like my cocktails
not fruity or juicy or sweet uh I like
more spirit-forward as they say so you
know I like martinis and Manhattans and
in the slightly more out there world I
like sazeracs and corpse Survivor number
two and stuff like that
um but you know honestly that Martini is
my favorite cocktail it's very simple
very easy to make you know you can't you
can mess it up people do mess it up but
I think it's pretty easy to make the
regular version of it I was just at a
party with not a party uh dinner at a
friend's house and he made martinis and
he didn't
he didn't use ice or make the martini
cold in any way and I could not hide my
disappointment and he felt he felt a
little sad that I didn't like his
Martini that much because it was all
room temperature but you know one of the
requirements is it should be super duper
cold that's my advice out there to
Martini makers
Simon Graf says as a good Bayesian what
do you think of higher order defeat
problems for example
how should we conditionalize on evidence
that our ability to conditionalize I.E
taking evidence into account is
currently impaired or Worse evidence
that conditionalization is not the right
rule for taking new evidence into
account some people who argue that
finding out you are drugged tired or
suffering from hypoxia puts us into
situations like this I think this is a
great question but I don't have a great
answer I haven't thought deeply about
these problems uh my my immediate guess
is you do your best if you were drugged
but didn't know it at all then I can't
think of a better strategy than just
trying to do the same thing that you
thought you were trying to do if you did
know it then that should be part of your
calculation of both your priors and your
likelihood function right if you are
seeing a pink elephant and you're like
oh that's very unlikely but then you go
also you're completely intoxicated then
it becomes more likely you change your
likelihood function right now I am a
good baby and I try to be a good
Bayesian but to be clear to be a good
Bayesian is to assign prior
probabilities to things and to try to
update them when new information comes
in it is highly impractical to actually
do that in the real world on a
comprehensive kind of basis you can do
that explicitly for certain claims
scientists do it you know when I was a
graduate student they didn't astronomers
and physicists were not bayesians
generally back in the 1980s and uh Big
Data came along and it became more clear
we had to be better bayesians and so now
when you read papers that are looking
for the Higgs boson or looking for using
CMB data to constrain cosmological
parameters everyone is Bayesian from the
start and that's very helpful but as a
practical matter no one really plugs in
Bayes theorem when they learn new
information in every day so situations
so just to be I'm all I'm trying to say
is that to be a good Bayesian is really
about trying your best to admit that you
have priors and to update them when you
get new information as best you can it's
not literally plugging in the formula
and in your if you're in these
situations where conditionalization is
not the right rule or something like
that if you're somehow cognitively
impaired you're probably going to be an
even worse Bayesian than a perfect
calculator would be you know if you go
back to the podcast we did with Carl
friston about the Bayesian brain and the
free energy principle
um the the brazian brain hypothesis is
about you know minimizing surprise like
trying like a brain is supposed to model
the world in such a way that it says the
least surprised that it can be when it
encounters new information but
even those people admit that that's a
calculationally implausible for the
brain to actually do it that's why you
invent the free energy principle the
free energy principle is kind of a way
to approximate being a good Bayesian so
I think that the real world is a lot
richer and a lot more complicated than
the perfect Bayesian Reasoner that we
imagine that these these uh higher order
defeat problems are examples of that I I
do not know of a particular correct
strategy to take that covers all of them
sorry about that
Henry Jacobs says I get the impression
that unitary Evolution and quantum
mechanics is analogous to volume
conserving evolution in classical
mechanics yes that is true classically
when dissipation is introduced we get
phase space contraction however
dissipation is secretly achieved it's
really two subsystems interacting where
one is large and called the environment
and typically sucks energy from the
smaller subsystem is there an analogous
conception of dissipation coupled
systems in quantum mechanics and can it
yield an explanation for the apparent
collapse of wave functions during
observations I would say yes absolutely
and in some sense okay so yes absolutely
there's a conception of dissipation for
coupled systems and quantum mechanics
Quantum systems become entangled with
each other that's an example okay when
you lose the purity of your Quantum
State because you're becoming entangle
with degrees of freedom elsewhere and
there are equations to govern this so if
you aren't tracking the environment or
whatever else it is you're becoming
entangled with if you're only track
taking the system of interest it's an
open system it is not going to obey the
Schrodinger equation so you do the same
kind of thing morally That You Do In
classical mechanics which is you say
what is the best approximation what is
the most realistic dynamical equation I
could posit that would more or less
track the evolution of my open system in
contact with environment that I am not
tracking and this is I'm sort of saying
this slowly and hesitatingly because
hopefully it should be clear you can't
get a perfect equation that would ever
do this because the thing is you don't
know what the environment is going to do
by hypothesis you're not tracking it
right if you try to model the Earth as
an open system but you don't know that
we're about to be hit by an asteroid
you're going to get your predictions
wrong the same thing is true in quantum
mechanics so you have equations you have
Master equations or the linblad equation
or you know various other things that
try to do this kind of thing by making
assumptions about the environment the
environment is a thermal bath It's
weekly coupled whatever assumption it a
set of assumptions it is you need to
make and you can do that and that often
works correctly in certain situations
but you shouldn't be overly confident in
its uh predictions it's you know they're
as good as
the Assumption the the conclusions are
as good as the assumptions let's put it
that way
now if you're asking whether it's an
explanation for the parent collapse of
wave functions it's half of an
explanation right all you're doing is
saying here D coherence D coherence is
the phenomenon that is predicted by
analyzing things in these ways some
people will say that decoherence
provides a solution to the measurement
problem of quantum mechanics why because
if you have an open system coupled to an
environment it can start in a
superposition of a a pure State Quantum
mechanically and it will evolve into a
statistical mixture of states and that
statistical mixture of States described
by a density Matrix will be a sum of
States whose coefficients are
non-negative numbers adding up to one
that is to say they look like
probabilities and in fact they precisely
are the probabilities that are predicted
by the born rule of quantum mechanics
okay so people will say look all I need
to do is have the coherence happen and
suddenly I have a probability
distribution over different states that
is all true but what you don't have is a
statement that says and you will find
yourself in one of those States once the
decoherence happens the rules of quantum
mechanics all by themselves say that you
would find yourself in a mixed state you
find yourself in a combination of all
these states and you find yourself in a
density Matrix in order to successfully
address the measurement problem and
understand the apparent collapse of the
wave function you have to make a set of
additional substantive claims your
substantive claim might be these
different parts of the density Matrix
now describe different branches of the
wave function and I am on one of them
and not others a different claim might
be there are hidden variables that point
to one of these one of these entries in
the density Matrix and that's the one
where I live other modification might be
the Schrodinger equation is violated and
the other entries in the density Matrix
no longer exist whatever they are but
this is all why we need theories of the
foundations of quantum mechanics you
can't explain what we see just by saying
that there is decoherence in the world
Michael says I am an atheist and
certainly no expert on religion or
Christianity however it does strike me
that Jesus seems to have been a really
good person a feminist even perhaps and
no toxic masculinity that I am aware of
I'm wondering what your thoughts are
regarding Jesus as a good person and as
a corrective to oppressive text found in
the Old Testament and if Jesus holds up
today as a model of non-oppressive
non-masculine toxic figures Etc
you know yes and no I uh in some senses
I have often said I'm 100 open to the
idea that we can find wisdom and
examples and inspiration in texts
whether they are religious texts or
secular texts or whatever if you want to
read the New Testament and find that
Jesus seems to you to be kind of like a
role model then go ahead I have no
objections to that whatsoever it's only
kind of partial because number one it's
very very hazy what the connection is
between the description of Jesus in the
New Testament and any actual human
person right
um there probably was a person named
Jesus Etc but the New Testament texts
were written decades after that person
died by people who are not eyewitnesses
to it so what are you going to believe
you know this is a set of stories that
we're told within a community and passed
down orally for a while before they ever
got written down so it's not clear that
you're actually looking up to a person
rather than a fictional character in
terms of what we are actually told about
them and the other thing is you know
some of the things that Jesus said were
really admirable and some were not like
most people you know that's why I don't
like hero Worship in any sense for Jesus
or for anybody else it's true that you
know he said a lot of good things about
turning the cheek and helping the poor
Etc he also said a lot of things about
going to hell if you didn't follow him
and you know maybe he was not as
misogynist as some of his contemporaries
but he certainly didn't say women and
men have equal status in my church I
don't I don't remember that one anywhere
in the New Testament certainly wasn't
followed in by his followers when they
actually set up the church so you know
go ahead I would say you know find
inspiration in Jesus and Buddha or uh
juanza or whoever you want to be
inspired by that's fine but you know
there's plenty people out there to be
inspired by not that one
Sid Huff says many people have been
taught that atoms are mostly empty space
this notion was stated eloquently by
none other than Carl Sagan however many
physicists debunked this statement as a
misconception so what exactly is empty
space does such a thing actually exist
whether inside atoms or elsewhere
well
you know you have to Define what you
mean by empty space and then you can
decide whether it exists I would not say
that atoms are empty space mostly
because I think that atoms are wave
functions right and the wave function as
a size you can literally plot it when
you look do look at all those orbital
diagrams in chemistry class that's the
size and shape of an atom in my way of
looking at it I don't see how anyone can
both really understand quantum mechanics
and claim that atoms are mostly empty
space because you have to in order to
say that atoms are mostly empty space
you have to think of an electron as a
little dot which we just know it isn't I
don't I know people are clinging to this
way of talking I don't blame Carl Sagan
at all because he was not a Quantum
physicist that was not his area of
expertise but there's you know modern
grown-up quantum mechanics people who
still talk that way even though they
really should know better then I really
just don't know there's other layers
here because of course we know these
days that Quantum field theory is a
better way of thinking of things than
Point particle quantum mechanics and
there the notion of empty space becomes
even more fraught let's put it that way
the closest you have in Quantum field
Theory to empty space is the vacuum
state so a state of your Quantum field
Theory where there are no particles no
excitations no energy of any sort
anything like that and you can have that
you know that's a pretty good
approximation to empty space to the
vacuum in between the planets and the
Stars it's not exact because there's
light and so forth right and you know
that means it's not completely empty but
it's a good approximation I'm not sure
what else we want other than that
Keith says say laplace's dark demon is
like laplace's demon except only knows
the exact state of dark matter the dark
demon also knows general relativity and
thus presumably would be able to infer
the presence of the clumped up ordinary
matter similar to how we ordinary beings
infer Dark Matter however the dark demon
is not aware directly of the laws of
physics governing the other interactions
of ordinary matter EG electromagnetism
my question is given these properties of
laplace's dark demon should we expect
the dark demon to still be able to infer
the state of the ordinary matter and
hidden laws just based on this perfect
dark and gravitational knowledge
well it would be hard so to rephrase the
question here if you knew if you were
perfectly knowledgeable about what all
the Dark Matter was doing and LaPlace
demon is supposed to be really smart
Okay so perfect calculational abilities
the ordinary matter in the universe
would have an effect on the motion of
the dark matter so could you infer the
physics of ordinary matter from just
what the dark matter is doing in some
sense of course this is just what we're
trying to do right now with the dark
matter we know about what the ordinary
matter is doing we're trying to figure
out what the dark matter is and we know
there that there are things we can learn
how much dark matter there is how it's
distributed to through the universe but
there are also things that elude us
right now is the Dark Matter heavy or
light is it axions or wimps or black
holes or neutrinos or who knows so
of course laplace's demon knows a lot
more than we do so I think it could go
pretty far it would certainly know that
ordinary matter has dissipation right so
it has some way of shaking off energy by
giving off photons and therefore
clumping and then coming to the bottom
of a gravitational potential well that
might naturally lead it to uh
understanding electromagnetism maybe
even atomic structure but then there's
other things it would not know like it
would never learn about the top Quark
because top quarks just Decay away heavy
particles don't really stick there in
the uh set of particles that we have
existing in the universe right now so
that would be very very difficult for
laplace's dark demon to figure out it
would probably even have difficulty with
something like the Higgs boson or the
Higgs mechanism because I not not sure
that the dark demon would ever be able
to figure out that there was parody
violation in the standard in what we
call the ordinary matter sector and
without parity violation you don't
really need the Higgs mechanism right
you can just have masses for particles
just like Dirac did when he first wrote
down the Dirac equation so my guess is
the Dark theme would be able to learn a
lot but certainly not everything about
our known laws of physics
Nicola Ivanov says if the second law of
Thermodynamics is applicable only to
isolated systems how can we think it is
applicable also to the observable
universe as a whole if we don't know
whether the observable universe is an
isolated system
well there's two things for one thing
there absolutely are versions of the
second law that are applicable to
non-isolated systems if you have a
system that is in contact with a heat
bath okay that is not isolated it's in
contact with a heat bath but it's a very
simple kind of non-isolation it's just
sort of being lured into thermal
equilibrium so in those cases you
absolutely have a version of the second
law that says that the sum of the
entropy increase plus the heat flow into
the environment is greater than zero so
something like that might still apply to
the universe but also more importantly
the second law is not posited as an
axiom of anything it is derived from the
behavior of physical systems we know
about core screening and about the
microscopic structure and things like
that and so if the universe is not an
open system it's not an open system if
our observable universe is thought of as
not an open system it's thought of is
not only system because things can
escape from it right there's a horizon
around us and things can leave the
Horizon it's not because things are
coming in to our universe and
influencing us so again that's a very
simple kind of non-openess and one that
can pretty easily be accommodated by
what we understand about the Dynamics of
the universe so we have every reason to
think that within our observable
universe entropy is going up
Russell wolf says it feels to me like
more often than not your response to
Priority questions is something along
the lines of I don't think this question
makes sense or I don't have much to say
about this when I'm listening to an AMA
and hear a priority question come up my
first reaction is to expect a less
interesting discussion because usually
you have more to say about the questions
you select freely how well do you feel
the system of priority questions is
working
well I'd be happy to get feedback from
patreon supporters about the priority
question system but I think it's working
okay uh it is true that a priority
question by its nature is one that I'm
gonna answer whether or not I think I
have anything interesting to say about
it my first Criterion for picking
questions to answer is whether or not I
have anything interesting to say so if
you remove that Criterion from
consideration there's going to be a
negative correlation with me having
negative interesting things to say but
that's not the only thing that matters
you know I want the amas to be useful
both for listeners who are not the
question askers and for the question
askers right both of those criteria
count so when I'm trying to choose
questions to answer mostly I'm thinking
about the listeners
I'm thinking about whether or not they
will want to hear my answer to this
question possibly you know I don't know
why they want to hear some of these
answers but you know I give it a shot
whereas when I'm thinking about the
priority questions I'm thinking about
the person asking the question I do you
know in the early days of the patreon
when it was smaller I could answer all
of the questions and I felt like I was
giving back a very definite tangible
benefit to patreon supporters I can't do
that anymore so the priority question
system was invented as a compromise
where if you have one burning question
that you want to ask even though I seem
to not be willing to answer it I'll give
you that chance you absolutely had that
chance and probably you will learn that
I wasn't answering it because I have
nothing interesting to say but that's
okay you know maybe I'll be able to
point in some direction or something
like that so again I'm open to people
suggesting changes in a priority
question system but I think so far it's
working more or less as I had hoped
Brent Meeker says what do you think of
various systems of voting such as rank
choice or distributed points have there
been simulations or empirical tasks of
how they work Arrow's theorem says that
all voting systems can be gained
I don't think Arrow system exact Arrow's
theorem exactly says that Arrow's
theorem says that certain kinds of
voting systems which are a lot of them
but not all of them in particular
um it applies to ranked Choice voting
but not to sort of voting systems where
you have a Continuum of preferences
right there are eroding systems where
you don't just rank your choices but you
assign a number to them you grade them
basically range voting uh so you say
well this option I give a 10 to this I
give a 7.3 this I got I give it two and
so forth arrows theorem doesn't
technically apply in those cases and
furthermore what Arrow theorem says is
not that all voting systems can be
gained it says that there are various
things you would like to be true about a
voting system such as you know no
dictator it's not just one person who
makes all the decisions and if two
people both rank a greater than b then
their you know combined ranking is a
greater than b things like that can't
all be simultaneous be satisfied what I
think you're probably thinking of is
strategic voting which is a related but
slightly different concept strategic
voting is when you have a set of
preferences but the most likely way to
get your favorite outcome is not to vote
honestly about what your preferences are
right so you might vote for a third
party you might not vote I should say
for a third party candidate not because
you don't like them but because you
don't think they're going to win you
know if if 45 percent of the people like
One candidate and 50 percent I'm not
going to get this true in real time if
40 40 45 and 15 right are the are the
voting things then you might worry that
if you give your money to the Third
Party candidate you're throwing it away
because they're not going to win so
instead you strategically vote for
somebody else so that's that's a true
but slightly different thing than arrows
theorem anyway
um I have mixed feelings about different
voting systems I do think that our
current voting system uh pluralistic
voting or first pass the post is the
worst I think that's a that's the
consensus of people who thought about
this
and I do think that right choice voting
is better I think that range voting like
I just described is even better although
it's still subject to strategic voting
considerations there was a study you
asked about a study you know does
anything work the best well what does it
mean to work the best right this is why
I'm interested in these questions
because it's not at all obvious how to
define what it means to work the best
but if you if you Google range voting
there was a study someone tried to do
you know a simulation of many many
different voting systems and uh invented
an idea called Bayesian regret you know
how sad is the individual voter that
their preferred candidate didn't win and
then you sum over all the voters and the
and range voting came out the best in
that particular set of simulations so
there is at least an attempt to be a
little empirical about this so it's not
on it well it's a numerical experiment
it's a thought experiment let's put it
that way it's not an actual empirical
investigation based on real voters and
that's why I'm a little bit skeptical
because there is a trade-off that voting
theorists don't want to face up to which
is that complicated systems are bad
complicated systems might help you
achieve some ideal solution in a thought
experiment but real people don't like
them right real people know what it
means to vote for a candidate they might
even understand what it means to rank
candidates but you can quickly get
elections like I was in California where
we had elections with over 200 people on
the ballot you think you're going to
rank all them
you have to do something right you have
to have some simplification so I don't
know how much work has been done about
you know people just not voting or
voting badly when you have these more
elaborate systems in place that's what I
would worry about uh it goes back up to
you know Linux versus Macintosh users
right people want a simple user
interface and the voting system is an
example of where that is an important
consideration
I'm gonna group two questions together
schleier says Elon Musk is famously a
fan of the simulation hypothesis it
seems to me that if I were a billionaire
I too would question the nature of my
perceived reality due to the sheer
unlikelhood of having that experience
it's not surprising that there's a
richest person but it would seem
surprising for me to be that person is
this bad reasoning or can the
atypicality of One's Own role in a
system serve as useful information about
the nature of the system
and Casey Mahone says I often hear
physicists reworking their ideas in
order to avoid boltzmann brain
situations but this seems to clash with
another idea I've heard you express
namely that we can't think of ourselves
as being uniformly selected among all
observers can't we just imagine that
there are boltzmann brains having their
own experiences near the end of time
while we're here now why would we change
a theory just because this is just the
possibility of boltzmann Reigns
somewhere else in space-time so the
Common Thread here is uh something we've
already mentioned earlier this episode
the idea that we are somehow typical
observers within some group of people
um I kind of am sympathetic with
schleier's uh suggestion that you know
if you were a truly non-typical person
and you thought that you should be
typical then that might suggest to you
that something was going on right but
you know guess what forget about
billionaires typical people are not
physics professors so I should have that
same kind of belief and this is exactly
why I don't think that we should think
that we're typical people because by the
time we're grown up and trained well
enough to have such thoughts we're
already not typical people we're
certainly not typical Arrangements of
atoms just by being people at all uh
this whole thought experiment is a weird
thing where you say okay here I am as a
real person with real facts and
characteristics about my life I'm going
to pretend to forget all of them I'm
going to pretend to forget that I know
who I am in the world pretend that I'm a
typical person and then real then you'll
wake up and look around and notice that
I am not typical and be surprised this
just seems weird to me like why are you
doing this why not just admit that
you're not typical okay so that's my
reasoning there now I'll confess very
very quickly I don't have a perfectly
well-formed alternative so I'm working
on that I'm trying to figure it out one
of the aspects of what I think is a much
better alternative is that if you have a
set of observers who have the same
information about their situation so if
you literally have observers that if you
ask them everything about who they were
would give you precisely the same answer
then you should imagine that you were
typical among that Ensemble of people so
you know if you if you think about a
duplication experiment right where you
step into a box and then you're turning
into identical people and you don't know
neither one of those two people know
which ones they are then you should give
50 50 chance to being either one what
else are you going to do right because
they're in epistemically
indistinguishable situations and so
that's why the boltzmann brain problem
is a big problem because it's not
because there are random fluctuations
into brains okay I know everyone says
that it's kind of evocative and
picturesque and people talk about that
but again this whole line of reasoning
that says if there were lots of
boltzmann brains I would be a boltzmann
brain I'm not one therefore it is ruled
out by the data I don't think that that
makes any sense at all the problem in
the boltzman brain situation is that
when there are fluctuations into
boltzmann brains there are also
fluctuations into people with exactly
your experiences
but people with exactly your experiences
in much different actual circumstances
okay the most obvious case is imagine a
fluctuation into exactly our universe
that we see around us right now but no
more if you if you want to fluctuate
into our universe as we see it you don't
literally need to make other galaxies
and stuff like that right you need to
make the photons that you and I and
astronomers observe from those galaxies
and use them to infer the existence of
galaxies it's much easier to fluctuate
into a few photons than to fluctuate a
whole galaxy
so the overwhelming majority of
observers in that kind of fluctuating
universe who see pictures of you know
galaxies far away tomorrow will not see
those pictures anymore those galaxies
will disappear because there were no
galaxies there there were just some
photons that randomly fluctuated into
existence that's the problem with this
scenario is that you make a strong
prediction that you don't really believe
now you notice I didn't say a strong
prediction that comes out false that's a
slightly different thing it's that you
don't really believe that prediction
because of the cognitive instability
aspects of your situation you have to
believe in that situation that all of
your purported information about the
universe is just randomly fluctuated and
therefore is completely unreliable and
therefore you can't actually make any
predictions about anything and that's no
way to go through life
so the belief that we are not boltzmann
brains
does not rely on the idea that we are
typical observers chosen among all
observers in the universe it does I do
think it is absolutely fair and indeed
the only thing to do to assume that we
are typical observers from the set of
people with exactly our information it's
completely cheating
to say that there are some observers in
a nice well-posed Universe like we think
we live in or or portion of the universe
and there are many more observers in the
future or in the past with exactly the
same epistemic situation but we're not
them
because how do you know you're not them
what's so great about you what why don't
they have feelings too right so I do
think that random fluctuation scenarios
should be excluded from our
consideration but not because of literal
boltzmann brains
Redmond says after extraterrestrial
contact requesting a meeting the
president a mindscape subscriber asks
you to lead the human team the aliens
who can speak English but not other
languages and are far advanced in the
art of meetings limit human
participation to five people who do you
take whom do you take sorry uh so I'm
not going to answer this question
literally uh it but I want to say two
things about it
um
the first thing is that the reason why
I'm not going to answer it literally is
because I'm just not
I'm just not into these kinds of
questions and you know I know that many
people are I'm not trying to denigrate
these kinds of questions but like pick
your five favorite people with
characteristics X those are just never
my favorite questions I'm just not into
them it's it kind of smacks a little bit
of hero worship I know it's not I'm not
trying to say that but you know who are
the five best people the five coolest
people I'm not about people in that way
you know but I like my friends my
personal acquaintances I'm about those
people but people out there in the world
you know who do great things for them
I'm about their great things I don't
know them personally enough to say you
know who are the five people in history
you'd want to have dinner with or
whatever you know I just I just don't
think that way and I apologize for it
because it makes me weird and makes me
sound like I'm being rude to people who
ask that question because that kind of
question is very common here in the amas
okay so I'm not going to give you
literal answers to it I feel like I've
been insulting all the people I didn't
pick you know but
um I do think that the question of What
kinds of people you would send to talk
to uh intelligent aliens is a really
good question you know forget about
individuals and their names what kind of
team would you assemble that's a great
question that's very interesting uh and
you know the short answer is I don't
know because you know one of the rules
of the amas here is I don't do any work
for them other than literally you know
editing them and then reading and
recording them so that's a question that
demands a lot of thought you know and I
haven't thought about it that's why I
like that aspect of the question
um you know you would it's smart that
you put in there in the question that
the aliens somehow speak English but not
other languages okay I don't know what
that happened but I guess I I do
recognize that it makes the question
much simpler so we don't need to send a
linguist right I mean clearly you would
want to send at least a very good
physical scientist and a very good
biological scientist right you'd want to
talk to them about science and I think
that you would separately want to send
someone who was really good at
technology you know being good at
technology is is different than being
good at science so you know someone who
can learn about from the aliens about
the fundamental laws of physics someone
who can learn from them about their
biology and someone who can learn about
them from them about their technology
just saying those words out loud you
know makes it very clear that even five
people is not going to be enough like
what do you mean someone who can learn
about technology like there's lots of
different kinds of Technologies people
who are good at superconductors are not
good at you know pharmaceutical advances
or something like that so it's going to
be a tough call and then I think you
want some more socially oriented people
you know maybe a social scientist and an
artist artist in the broadest sense you
know literature movies or whatever but
you know someone who has a more poetic
narrative sensibility would be a good
person to talk to the alien and also
someone who knows something about social
dynamics
to figure out you know what the society
is like of the aliens and something like
that so that's that seems like to me to
be a pretty good first attempt at five
different kinds of people but you know
it's leaving out people who are
interested in
um diseases people are interested in
astronomy people who know about uh
complex systems in general uh people who
are politically smart people who could
negotiate very well you know there's a
whole bunch of skill sets not in that
team so I'm just going to cross my
fingers and hope that we get 10 people
on our team when we finally meet the
aliens
Adam small says priority question
this has to do with black holes from
what I understand the effect of gravity
move or the speed of light so if the sun
if the sun suddenly took off and jetted
out of the solar system the Earth would
still revolve for a while uh until the
information arrived this relates to
black holes because since the signal of
gravity moves and starts inside the
Event Horizon where the source of
gravity is how does the information of
gravity Escape The Event Horizon since
gravity does move and reach an orbiting
star I thought no information can escape
other than Hawking radiation
there's a whole bunch of things going on
here that I'll try to talk about a
little bit you know first thing it's not
really relevant to the question but it's
useful information these kind of thought
experiments where you say if the sun
suddenly took off and jetted out of the
solar system this already doesn't make
sense because it violates energy
conservation like what do you mean
suddenly took off the whole mass of the
Sun suddenly has a different momentum so
you're already violating the laws of
physics and then you're saying well what
would the laws of physics have to say
about this that's an inconsistent
question you need a better and you can
fix it up right you say like what if the
Sun exploded but if it exploded in a you
know in two blobs moving off in opposite
directions like the sun decayed into two
mini Suns going in opposite direction so
that's a fixable kind of thing but just
so you know that kind of thing would
have to be fixed in order to ask a
sensible question but the other thing
the more important thing about the
question is this idea that gravity is
kind of a substance that moves at a
speed that's just not what gravity is
for that matter it's not what
electromagnetism is Right both gravity
electromagnetism are fields that pervade
space-time and solve some equations and
so the right question to ask is what is
the solution of the equations with
certain boundary conditions in the case
of a black hole or the Sun the boundary
conditions are there's some mass or some
effective curvature of space-time
located at some part of the universe and
with that boundary condition you solve
the equations around it and you find
that there is a inverse Square law for
both gravity and for electromagnetism
it's not because there's some flux of
stuff when you have a Charged particle
with an electric field around it it's
not because
electromagnetism forces are moving away
from the particle and reaching out and
grabbing other things it's because at
every point in space there is an
electromagnetic field and it settles
down to a certain configuration given in
that boundary condition that there is a
charged particle at that point likewise
for Gravity there's nothing moving
faster than the speed of light in a
static gravitational field there isn't
anything moving at all it's static so it
is true that if the sun changed its
configuration dramatically for example
by splitting into and moving off then
the boundary condition for the
gravitational field would change and
that change would not be noticeable to
us in some reference frame because it's
relativity until what is it eight
minutes later because we're eight light
minutes away from the Sun but that's
completely compatible right that's just
the equation for the gravitational field
now has a different boundary condition
and those changes Ripple out at the
speed of light so it all does make sense
but you have to like make sure that your
intuitive model of what gravity is is
actually matching up with the what the
equations are telling you
Anonymous says clocks that I care about
are usually a flow meter for entropy
when I sit to think for a minute I'm
waiting for a minute's worth of entropy
increase to happen in my brain
regardless of how light would travel in
that time
but some clocks aren't entropic like the
T you take derivatives with respect to
in hamiltonians can you say something
smart and at the limits of my
comprehension about these two kinds of
clocks
I think I can try to say something uh
useful anyway whether or not it's smart
and at your limits but I think that
you're probably not right to think about
clocks as flow meters for entropy it is
true that in some certain physical
circumstances clocks do in participate
in the overall increase of the entropy
of the universe but the thing about
entropy increasing is it doesn't
increase at a constant rate
entropy can stay constant in some system
for a long time and then start going up
or whatever right there's no law of
physics that says entropy goes up at a
certain rate the second law just says
the entropy doesn't go down sometimes
it'll stay constant sometimes it'll go
up and so forth and for precisely that
reason most clocks they work very very
hard to isolate them from entropy the
simplest clocks in the world are the
rotation of the earth and so you see the
Sun going up and down right and that
does not increase entropy at all it's in
the you know in the limit where you can
ignore some very very tiny effects which
is a very good approximation it's
completely reversible right we know
where the Sun and the Earth were
millions or billions of years ago so
clocks are usually not flow meters for
entropy they're usually periodic things
that do the same thing over and over
again in a way that is completely
constant in entropy so that's the actual
time that you measure with clocks if you
think about what are the best clocks
they're the things that are like a
pendulum where you have no air
resistance or little tiny quartz crystal
or an atomic vibration all things that
are not actually spewing entropy out
there into the universe
Robbie P says you've said that the
question why is there something rather
than nothing is not a sensible one but
in some sense isn't nothing all around
us or right around the corner in any
possible regime why aren't we forced to
choose between necessary and contingent
whatever the universe
well sure you know when you say why is
there something rather than nothing it
would be nice if you told us what you
meant by the words something and nothing
I think that the most traditional
interpretation of that question is why
is there anything at all and things like
empty space are not nothing at all
they're full of quantum fields and you
know that they have a metric and they
have a dimensionality and all these
characteristics it's not like there's an
absence of anything okay so I do not
think that it is true that nothing is
all around us or right around the corner
uh of course you're also welcome to ask
that why is space not empty that's a
perfectly good question you know there's
this there's this saying that goes
around in certain circles that uh the
reason why there's something rather than
nothing is because nothing is unstable
this is an extraordinarily annoying
saying because generally the people who
say it don't know what it means or what
they're talking about that was a little
uh ma Auto invented by Frank wilcheck
former mindscape guest where he was
specifically referring to the question
of why there is more matter than
anti-matter in the universe why there is
a baryon asymmetry so it was kind of
like a little joke you know why is there
more matter than anti-matter because in
his particular model which we don't know
is true by the way he had a system where
uh an equal amount of matter and
anti-matter was an unstable circumstance
an unstable configuration of stuff so
it's a conjectural model but it's also
not at all what most of us have in mind
when we ask why is there something
rather than nothing so like many big
sounding questions the very first thing
you should do when you ask it if you
actually care about what the answer is
is to carefully Define exactly what you
mean by those terms
Christopher Matthews says I've noticed
that occasionally you'll get groups of
questions concerning topics or
conclusions that you dismiss as
misguided or even woo-woo and in these
cases I further notice that the
questions often appear to have been
inspired by a recent video from pop
science YouTube series like PBS
space-time what is your feeling
generally about these sort of video
series do you think they do a good job
communicating physics concept to a
general audience even if they apparently
cause a rash of misguided speculation
from time to time
I think that's a perfectly reasonable
question I don't have a lot of data on
the basis of which to answer it I
personally don't spend a lot of time
watching pop science YouTube videos and
I say that slowly and carefully because
I don't want to disparage pop science
YouTube videos and certainly not
disparage the people who watch them I
love it that there are pop science
YouTube videos just like popscience TV
documentaries or pop science books Etc
it's not my thing because I'm a
professional scientist and therefore if
I'm reading science it's probably going
to be a little bit more technical than
those things and if I'm reading popular
fun things it's probably not going to
have anything to do with science okay
that's just who I am particularly so I
don't have an educated view on which
science videos are the good ones and
which ones are not like I said I like
the idea that there are science videos
and I I'm glad that they're trying
I do think there's one possible
criticism or potential criticism that uh
or potential Pitfall let's put it that
way that people should should worry
about
because
different science questions have
different levels of
straightforwardness to their answers
right like let's think about our atom's
empty space like we were just talking
about that's not a trivial question it's
not you know it's not like how big is a
black hole of a certain Mass there you
just go to the equation you plug it in
you get the answer so you can have a
mind-blowing popular science video about
the journey into a black hole how long
it would take when you would get
spaghettified when you could reach a
point and not read no return what you
would see is you were looking outside
all of those are interesting questions
but the answers to them are ultimately
perfectly straightforward there are
other kinds of questions that sound
similar right are atoms mostly empty
space how hard can that be but in fact
they involve very deep potentially
controversial issues about the
foundations of quantum mechanics or
things like that and I do think that
some sometimes in these pop science
videos it's not that they get them wrong
it's that at least not they get them
wrong because they're being sloppy it's
because they're addressing questions
which are legitimately tricky and a lot
of professional scientists get them
wrong you know
um scientists are sloppy all the time
when they're talking about science
scientists will say things that they
know what the footnotes and the caveats
are but are not immediately conveyed
when they say those things scientists
will say you know the Universe on large
scales is either flat or positively
curved or negatively curved if you
really sat down and interrogated them
they would know that's not right they
would know that's a set of assumptions
that you're making they're only
approximately true like there's a whole
bunch of caveats that they have in mind
that they're not sharing with you and so
they're not lying to you they're just
not telling you the whole story and then
someone goes and makes a video about it
and someone else thinks it's just true
and all the footnotes and caveats and
and careful wordings have gone away
right and so that is a danger in making
these kinds of videos and I say to
someone I've not made a lot of science
videos on YouTube myself but I've been
on I've been in science documentaries
all the time and you know the people in
in the in Hollywood where they make
these little one-hour shows for the
Science Channel or the History Channel
or the Discovery Channel
the people who are making these shows
are on the one hand entirely
um well-meaning
and on the other hand know nothing about
science and I say that you know without
any disparagement their job is making TV
shows there are not people in general
there's always exceptions but for the
most part the director of a TV science
show is not his his job is not or her
job not director of TV science shows
right it's director of TV shows and
science just happens to be what their
job is this day that's even true for the
writers and the producers and so forth
so you get a lot of situations where you
know they saw something on Wikipedia or
whatever they don't really understand it
perfectly they're trying their best to
turn it into something Visual and they
do understand visual things so they'll
try to make a nice fun visual
demonstration of something and not
really have a very good idea of what the
thing is that they're demonstrating so
like anything else in the world you
should be skeptical you should keep your
wits about you when you watch these
things you should really think about
okay this is being said to me on the
internet does that necessarily mean that
it's true
Jake zielsdorf says do you have opinions
about Oppenheimer as a physicist was he
a great one well I think that you know
he has contributions uh in physics he
was not you know in the top tier in
terms of contributions you will hear
again and again that people who knew him
and met him claimed that he was in the
top tier in terms of just being
brilliant but that's a different thing
right there's plenty of brilliant people
who don't do anything at all I would say
that Oppenheimer did some pretty good
things
um but not you know earth-shattering
things as far as physics is concerned he
did do an earth-shattering thing and
leading the Manhattan Project you know
for better for worse that was an
enormous accomplishment personally so uh
you know that in that sense he he
succeeded at doing something other than
writing theoretical physics papers and I
think you know that's fine there are
ways to have an impact on the world
other than writing physics papers
Tim Converse says and acquaintance of
mine once looked at my bookshelves and
declared that my interest looked a mile
wide and an inch deep which was mean but
fair
as a person with an unusually large
volume of Interest how do you think
about the trade-off between breadth and
depth of your interests and your
intellectual work or do you not think of
it that way
well I think there is a trade-off you
know I think there's a finite number of
days in the week years in your lifetime
cycles of activity in your brain Etc so
if you are going to uh educate yourself
and think very very broadly about many
different topics then you will
not be able to focus on any one of those
topics as deeply as you would if you
only focused on that one topic I think
you just can't deny that for any one
person
saying that by itself certainly doesn't
tell us whether it is better to hyper
specialize and focus on one topic or to
cast your net more broadly for obvious
reasons you know there's an obvious
benefit to hyper-specializing which is
you can just always be thinking about a
certain kind of thing dig very deeply
into it you can understand its nuances
really really well and there's an
underappreciated aspect which is that
thing is what you're thinking about in
your spare time you know as you're
brushing your teeth as you're walking to
work you're just thinking about that one
thing and that constant concentration on
something is very valuable to really
making breakthroughs there's just no
doubt about that
there is also value in not falling into
a rut in being constantly exposed to
different ways of thinking and different
ways of conceptualizing things and
putting things together and so even if
your ultimate goal is to understand
questions in a certain particular field
one can make the argument for also
thinking about other fields and learning
about them even if it cuts down on the
time that you get to put in the in the
particular field that you're most
interested in you know all of that is
all true and I just said it you know
it's all true but honestly I just like
what I do I kind of don't care whether
other people think that I'm uh a mile
wide in an inch deep or anything like
that am I that's for other people to
judge what matters to me is that I have
a job that you know lets me do what I
want to do if I didn't you know then I
would feel bad uh but now I do so I'm
happy there you go that's what I care
about now
what is the broad scale best way to
deploy our intellectual resources I
don't know I think that it's not that
different from what we do which is that
we have some people who are super duper
specialized and we have other people who
like to be a little bit more Broad and
interdisciplinary and they talk to each
other
I do think that probably if I were again
you know the the god emperor of Academia
I would tilt the scales a little bit
more toward broad people
interdisciplinary people because it's
just kind of easier and cheaper to stick
to a field and just do the same thing
over and over again I think that there's
low hanging fruit that gets missed by
not rewarding people who try to make
connections across Fields but it's a
small effect it's not like throwing I
don't want to stop all those people who
are specializing I don't want to
denigrate their work in any way I think
you know everyone should like being I I
always say this being a professor being
an academic being an intellectual you
gotta do it because you love it there's
no that's really the only reason you
know like if you have other motivations
in your life there's better ways to
um have them fulfilled than being a
professor in various ways of course
being a professor also involves teaching
and things like that which is all so
important I'm just thinking about the
research intellectual project aspect of
them and if you love it you love it in
different ways different people will the
love for knowledge and research and
learning new things will manifest itself
in different ways in different people
and I think that's good I'm not really
about ranking all the different ways and
figuring out what is the right one
some dude says priority question I've
sometimes tried to explain Quantum field
Theory to friends with the image with
the analogy of a TV or computer screen
the pixels on a monitor may be turned on
or off but they're always there
basically pixels having the potential to
be on off is analogous to discrete
pockets of individual field having the
potential to be excited or not do you
think this is an apt analogy yeah
actually I think it's a very good
analogy I think that people because
we're used to in the classical limit
thinking about particles and objects do
tend to think of the world as stuff in
the forms of object with objects with
empty space in between them and Quantum
field Theory or for that matter even
classical field Theory the quantum
really doesn't have that much to do with
it field Theory says the opposite field
Theory says that even in the emptiest of
spaces there still are fields they might
have their lowest possible value zero or
whatever that is but they're still there
so this kind of analogy with a TV screen
where some pixels are just off but the
pixels are still there that's perfectly
good I like it
Sean Miller says evolutionary principles
taken in their broadest sense to mean
change over time and selective pressures
that favor certain kinds of change
arguably are as fundamental as the
second law in this sense one can think
of the second law as a demon favoring
patterns of matter that favor increased
entropy do you think there's any utility
in thinking of the evolution of the
universe with this lens or does
fundamental physics and the principle of
least action essentially render any
notion of selective pressure at this
level nonsensical
you know this is a complicated set of
questions here
um you're you're a little worried in the
phrasing of the question because you
leap from entropy and uh evolutionary
pressures to fundamental physics in the
principle of least action and you know
all these are good ideas but they're
ideas in different contexts you know if
you have fundamental physics in the
principle of least action you don't talk
about entropy or Evolution or selection
you just follow the laws of physics and
you just do what they do the idea of
entropy and and selection and evolution
only comes about when you've core
screened and you have an arrow of time
Etc
I don't like as I sort of implicitly
said earlier I don't like to think about
the second law favoring patterns of
matter that favor increased entropy the
second law is just an inequality it's
very very weak
it says that along a trajectory entropy
could either go up or go down and it
goes up doesn't say that it tries to go
up as fast as it can doesn't say what
way it goes up it doesn't say how
rapidly it goes up it just says it
doesn't spontaneously go down that's a
very very weak requirement okay what we
would like to do and maybe what you're
gesturing at is we would like to go
beyond the second law of Thermodynamics
to really understand the ways in which
physical large-scale configurations of
matter evolve to both increase entropy
but also have other finer scale things
going on complex systems interacting
with each other biological systems and
things like that that's something I'm
very very interested in but you can't
just appeal to the second law of
Thermodynamics the second law is just
like the dumbest simplest thing in this
context you need to think beyond that
and it's not clear what the rules beyond
that are so these are open research
problems I would say
nalita s says as a theoretical physicist
is there a road map as to how you
creatively come up with new theories
that is being followed by all
theoretical physicists or does every
theoretical physicist build their own
road map into new territory like
individualized how does that
mind-blowing creative process take off
I think it's closer to everyone as an
individual I mean in fact if you think
about the training of the theoretical
physicist right you know you go to
undergraduates you take some classes you
do a bunch of problem sets you go to
graduate school you have an advisor you
take some more classes but mostly now
you're trying to do research and get
papers written and so forth but there's
no class you take about how to be
creative how to come up with new
theories I always think back to Zen and
the Art of Motorcycle Maintenance which
among other things it's a long book but
there's a lot in there about the
philosophy of science and one point in
there about the philosophy of science is
the baconian scientific method Francis
Bacon back in the day trying to explain
how science Works he says you know
formulate a hypothesis use the
hypothesis to make predictions test the
predictions right and persig Robert
persig in Zen In The Art of Motorcycle
Maintenance points out other people have
also pointed out but he did it very
vividly
Step One is a doozy formulate a
hypothesis what do you mean formulated
hypothesis how many hype how do you do
that who says the rules of formulating
hypotheses there's potentially an
infinite number of them out there how do
you choose which ones to formulate
that's the creative process and I don't
think there's anything mystical or
woo-woo about it but it's also not
axiomatized or algorithmetized we don't
have a uniform agreed upon way to
formulate hypotheses in fact it's not
even a single step you know formulating
hypotheses is a process it takes time
you sort of get a vague idea and you
think about it you know what does it
mean how can I write down equations that
would represent this oh how do I change
it now maybe I have different equations
maybe it refers to something different
all before you get to the point of
saying okay let's make predictions with
it test them things like that and I
think consistent with things I just said
that different people do it differently
and that's good good I think you need a
bunch of very different kinds of
approaches you know it's probably overly
simplistic but think of Einstein
he had a certain style right and at the
moment when his when his contributions
were called for in the Years you know
from 1900 to 1920. uh his style was
perfect it was exactly what the moment
called for but then after that even
though I will defend his understanding
of quantum mechanics and physics more
generally uh he was Einstein after all
but his productivity waned and partly
that's because he was busy doing other
things being a celebrity but partly
because the the techniques he had used
before were no longer that useful for
the moment of time that he was in I
think this is very often true in
theoretical physics that it's a match
between your personal Style and what is
out there to be discovered and
formulated right and the latter you have
no control over so all you can do is the
best you can do given your personal
style and your strengths and your
individual toolbox and hopefully the
world is right ready for what you have
to offer to it
Anonymous asks a priority question
um starting I need to know if this makes
any sense let's say we have an energy
density that can be described by the
equation y equals one between zero and
one
so if we integrate y equals 1 from 0 to
1 uh presumably zero and one go from x
equals zero to x equals one so we have
two variables we get the sum of x from
zero to one which equals one it's just
the area under the Curve
y equals one between x equals zero and x
equals one I agree with that that's all
true
now the question continues let's change
the energy density such that it follows
the equation y equals sine X plus cosine
X
the volume of the original total energy
still equals one just how it is
described has changed so I'm pausing
here there's a lot more I'm editing the
question out you're welcome to go read
it on the patreon page but there's a lot
of details here but sadly this there's a
a flub right there there's a kind of an
issue we have to uh confront y equals
sine X plus cosine X does not have an
integral between 0 and 1 that equals one
maybe if it were sine squared X plus
cosine squared x it would equal one
because sine squared X plus cosine
squared x equals one at every point so
it's just the same curve that you
decomposed in some way but sine X plus
cosine X does not have an integral that
equals one so mathematically that's a
boo-boo and then there's some extra
steps that I'm skipping but it's along
these lines of having some functions and
integrating them and so forth and then
the question concludes by saying a
proton can be defined as containing
three quarks specifically two up and two
and one down on properties of Quark
include up Quark equals charge of minus
one third spin of one-half Etc so I I
will you know the priority question is
you know does this make any sense and my
answer is no it does not make any sense
I think but there's I can do more than
that I hope I can I can be a little bit
more constructive here
um when you're trying to think about
things like how quarks work how energy
works things like that
um this is I mean maybe this is not what
you want to hear but a lot of people
have thought about this already right
and they're not all dummies they've said
really important things like the whole
existence of upworks and down quarks Etc
and they have a way of thinking about
them and I and I understand I don't
really know specifically about the
author the anonymous author of this
question but I know lots of examples of
people with similar ideas and almost
never do they understand
the basic mainstream view of how quarks
and gluons and things like that work the
idea based on Quantum field Theory and
Quantum chromodynamics Etc and there's a
desire or an aspiration maybe just to
skip ahead to some deep insight about
particle physics and and quarks and
leptons and things like that my personal
view which always could be wrong but my
personal view is you're not ever going
to skip the hard part and get an
interesting surprising truthful insight
into how these things work that's not
because the conventional way of looking
at it using Quantum field Theory and qcd
Etc refinement diagrams is necessarily
right maybe there's a better way of
doing it or a different way of doing it
I'm very open to that but I strongly
believe the chances of finding a better
way of doing it without first completely
understanding and conceptualizing the
usual way of doing it are negligible or
close to zero because the knowledge that
we have and it's not just you know
favoring the mainstream view it's that
the knowledge we have is very very
detailed and specific
you know when we talk about
quarks and gluons to people who are
non-physicists it doesn't sound that
complicated you know how many few quarks
and they're bound together etc etc and
you might get the impression that you
can sort of think this through yourself
and come up with something new but the
physicists are hiding stuff from you
they're hiding entire books worth of
knowledge about
fermions and propagators and Feynman
integrals and the fidaya of Popov ghosts
and dimensional regularization and
effective and it goes on and on and on
scaling behavior and things like that
asymptotic freedom
um you need to understand that stuff and
so if you really want to
make a contribution if he really wants
to push our knowledge forward in some
direction then do the work do the work
of understanding Quantum field Theory
buy a book buy the textbook it's hard I
know that it's hard but you can do it
anyone can do it any person who is you
know more or less has their average
scale mental faculties around them if
they really really wanted to they could
learn Quantum field Theory and qcd it's
a big project it will take you a long
time it'll be very frustrating but you
could do it I encourage you to do it if
that's what you want to do and if that's
not what you want to do then again I
will repeat my personal opinion which is
that the chances of hitting on some new
useful way to think about the physics of
those systems of quarks and gluons is
very very small because we know a lot
and you're starting at an enormous
disadvantage by not figuring out what it
is we already know
Seamus Maxwell says this question is
inspired by your advice to physics
Consultants on science fiction movies to
treat the script as data if you woke up
tomorrow in a fantasy world peopled by
Orcs elves and dragons and everything
seemed as real to you as the world you
currently inhabit would what would be
your best guesses as to what was
happening would there be any room in
your Creedence spread for something
other than dream hallucination and if so
what might it be
sure I think that the initial Credence
would be very highly peaked on dream
hallucination or you know being fooled
right by being given some drugs or
something like that uh or whatever but
of course what happens in these
situations is that it's not an All or
Nothing call in terms of what your
credences are the credences that you
should have as as I say about being part
of being a good Bayesian is essentially
no propositions should get zero Credence
from the start it might be a
sufficiently small Credence that you
don't sweat it that you don't really
worry about it in your everyday life but
waking up tomorrow and being surrounded
by Orcs And elves is not my everyday
life so I would have to start thinking
about the Wilder regions of proposition
space
and yeah you know the possibility that
there's a Multiverse and somehow my
conscious perceptions got moved from a
world of um
people and cats and dogs to a world of
dragons and elves it would be non-zero
right or maybe that's the true world all
along and I've been dreaming about this
mundane world of of podcasts and social
media and and what have you so I don't
know what my actual credences would be
but I absolutely would be
increasing over time my Credence and
something that I would now consider to
be incredibly dramatic and unlikely
Philip malinowski says I don't want to
get you in hot water I'm sorry I don't
want to get you in hot water but I'm
curious where do you stand on letting
your cats roam free Outdoors on the one
hand it's good to let the cats be cats
but on the other there are they are
incredible killing machines and may kill
a few hundred animals a year
uh I think that's true but I think
that's not the reason why I don't do it
so we do not let our cats roam free
outdoors I think it's a very highly
context specific question if I lived on
a farm in the middle of nowhere or just
in a cabin in the woods then maybe I
would let the cats roam Outdoors but
even then I would have some
um
concerns about it because domestic cats
are as the name says domesticated you
know they're not attuned they're not
selected for a successful life Outdoors
so yes they will kill a lot of birds and
squirrels and and mice and things like
that and they will also be very
vulnerable to being killed by Coyotes or
Wolves or or dogs for that matter or or
just having an accident
so all that is part of the cycle of life
like I don't mind that I don't mind that
cats kill animals I don't mind the cats
are killed by other animals we're all
gonna die someday that is not the thing
to mind the thing that I mind is that I
have a personal connection to certain
cats my cats and I want them to remain
safe so I personally would like my cats
to just stay indoors especially because
I do not live in the country I live
literally in the city of Baltimore not
too far away from highways and certainly
right next to all sorts of streets and
and what have you that we actually you
know I live in a part of Baltimore that
it's right next to the Johns Hopkins
campus but it's kind of leafy you know
it's kind of a lot of trees and things
like that and it kind of wild and a kind
of a lot of wildlife we've certainly
seen both foxes and deer
in you know walking by our house okay so
there's a little bit of wildlife out
there certainly squirrels and birds all
over the place so the cats would be
happy out there when they notice the
squirrels and birds maybe less happy
when they notice the foxes and Falcons
also we have a couple of Falcons nearby
so it's kind of weird to live in a city
and have all this nature around you but
but so be it
um I grew up in the suburbs and we had
cats and they were all outdoor cats and
and guess what their life expectancy is
much shorter I never had a cat die of
natural causes
um when I was growing up but you know
well one got leukemia I guess but I
guess I guess that's a natural cause but
usually yeah being hit by a car is how
the cats die so it just makes sense to
me that if you are entering into this
particular relationship where you take
care of the cat and or have
responsibility for it keeping it indoors
is a much more sensible thing
OA or however one pronounces owe says
when eternalists say that every moment
of time is equally real how does that
intersect with relativity where there is
no such thing as simultaneity and the
moments of time for one Observer are not
consistent with other observers on
different paths
that's perfectly fair question typically
relativity and eternalism go very
comfortably together in fact one
argument against presentism presentism
is the leading alternative to eternalism
so a presentist rather than saying that
every moment of time is equally real
would say that only the now is real
right now is real in the past and future
are just predictions and memories that
is what is very hard to reconcile with
relativity because people don't agree on
what now means once you extend yourself
from one point in space to other points
in space so presentism and relativity
are not happy with each other certain
people manage to nevertheless you know
figure out ways to believe both at the
same time
but eternalism and relativity are
generally taken to be 100 compatible
except that the way that we say what
eternalism means needs to be just a
little bit more carefully said so it's
true that eternalism is often explained
as every moment of time is equally real
really what you should say is every
event in space-time is equally real it's
not that there is some preferred way of
slicing space-time into moments of time
that is a perfectly legitimate critique
of the way that we talk about eternalism
Benjamin barbrel says I learned
listening to your podcasts and videos
that a black hole has a very large
entropy if entropy still means in this
context the number of microstates
corresponding to a different a given
macro State I don't understand the
nature of these microstates in the case
of a black hole it sounds incompatible
with the statement that a black hole has
no hair I feel like if a black hole had
many microstates it would lead to a
resolution of the information Paradox
since the state of another system thrown
in the black hole would just end up
encoded in those degrees of freedom
good is a very good question
um it does entropy still does in this
context mean the number of microstates
corresponding to a given macro state but
you know let's think carefully about
what that means and it's subtle and we
also have to remember something we said
much earlier in ama that in quantum
mechanics the way that we talk about
mixtures of states is a little bit
different okay so think about a box of
gas that has a lot of entropy it has a
lot of microstates that look that way
there are a lot of ways of arranging the
atoms and molecules and positions and in
velocities that have the same general
you know density and pressure and
temperature and things like that but
also a box of gas has no hair right
macroscopically the box of gas is going
to look exactly the same as a different
box of gas with the same temperature and
pressure even in a different micro state
so Quantum mechanically that becomes
even more Vivid the fact that you can
have no hair and yet you have a lot of
microstates because you have a certain
combination of those microstates that is
the thermal equilibrium combination that
is a combination of many many states and
therefore it has high entropy but it's a
particular exact combination of those
many many states so it's not like a
classical statistical combination of
things where there's literally different
kinds of microstates and you they're
sorry I should say where there literally
is a microstate that is the real one and
you just don't know it right in the
quantum case it truly is a mixture of
many different microstates in a definite
combination and that's what the black
hole would be like so a black hole
purportedly is a thermal mixture of a
large number of very specific Quantum
States in a very specific Arrangement
now
you are right to wonder what those
microstates are because nobody knows
that's a big part of the puzzle of
quantum gravity the cosmic no hair
theorem is exactly the thing that made
people kind of wonder about this how can
a black hole have so much entropy if all
black holes are the same if they have
the same mass in charge and spin but
that's that's mixing up a classical way
of talking the cosmic no hair theorem
with a Quantum way of talking the
entropy we hope the resolution is that
Quantum mechanically there is a large
set of microstates we don't know what
they are we did have Andy strominger on
the podcast a while back and Andy and
kormunwafa looked at this for a very
very simple kind of black hole a highly
supersymmetric black hole in very
special circumstances and in string
theory with d brains they could actually
identify the microstates that is much
harder to do in the general real world
situation so the short answer is we
don't know but I can say a that even if
there are that many microstates it does
not by itself resolve the information
Paradox because there is the extra
question of where the information is the
information Paradox is not just we don't
have enough room to put the information
in the black hole the information
Paradox is we need to get it out in the
Hawking radiation so if I have a book
and I throw it into the black hole if it
goes into the middle of the black hole
and then in the future it will hit the
singularity how do I get that
information out into the radiation even
though the Event Horizon might be very
far away from where the book is right
that's an important part of the black
hole information puzzle
Pete Faulkner says I've heard you and
others state that microscopic black
holes are a possible Contender as the
dark matter doesn't Hawking radiation
suggest that any such black holes would
have radiated away quickly or is the
suggestion that they are somehow being
constantly created no the suggestion is
just that you have to run the numbers
you know like for many questions like
this you can't just use words you gotta
kind of think about the numbers it is
true that a sufficiently small black
hole will evaporate away in a time scale
less than the age of the universe but a
larger black hole would take longer than
that to radiate away so you've got to
sit down and ask yourself how massive
does the black hole need to be for its
lifetime to be longer than the current
age of the universe and I actually don't
know what the answer is but the answer
is big but not that big it doesn't need
to be like the mass of the Sun if you
have a black hole of mass of the Sun its
lifespan is going to be way way longer
than the than the age of the universe
today so you can have black holes that
are quite a bit bit smaller than the Sun
that are truly microscopic in some sense
and yet have not yet evaporated away in
the age of the Universe from Hawking
radiation
red Antonov says if the tension between
the measured magnetic dipole moment of
the muon and its theoretical value is a
sign of new physics should we expect to
see deviations in other Precision
measurements of electromagnetic
properties for example would there be
hints of it in electric dipole moment
studies of neutrons or electrons
absolutely yes there should be but again
you got to run the numbers you know you
can't just say well it's a different
thing go measure it right some things
are easier to measure than others the
thing about the muon is it's heavier
than the electron so that means that
it's coupling to other particles
especially the Higgs and so forth is a
Little Bit Stronger
and therefore and you know just heavier
particles more generally therefore new
physics effects might very naturally
show up more readily in a muon than in
an electron an electron is kind of
shielded from effects of heavier
particles just because its mass is lower
neutrons on the other hand they are
heavier but they're a mess because
there's you know lots of quarks going on
inside it's hard to make the predictions
for what they should be so a muon is
sort of at a sweet spot where it's heavy
enough that maybe there's new physics
there it is simple enough that you can
actually calculate what you expect to
observe even given that by the way it's
not easy to make that calculation
because part of that calculation is that
there are strongly interacting particles
that are virtual particles that will
contribute to things like the magnetic
dipole moment of the muon that's why you
know there's different theoretical
calculations that don't agree with each
other which is probably the reason why
that's probably the reconciliation of
the Modern muon Electric dipole moment
issue it's probably not that there's
really new physics it's probably just
that the calculations are hard and we
haven't done them correctly I say that's
probably true it might not be true and
hopefully it's not fingers crossed that
it's really new physics but there's a
simple non-new physics explanation on
the table here namely that the
calculations are not good yet
Eric wonlick says you've been tasked
with coming up with a video game idea
that heavily utilizes a concept from
physics that is normally difficult for
people to visualize because it is not
part of our everyday life for example
four-dimensional space What concept do
you choose
this is going to be a very boring answer
but I choose four-dimensional space I
think that's a great thing this is like
I've mentioned this before that either
in video games or even even more
obviously in some truly immersive VR
experience I'm very curious as to
whether you could train people to think
in terms of four-dimensional space to
sort of visualize it to move around
there's nothing in the laws of physics
that say I can't visualize being in
four-dimensional space but there is a
lot in biology and and evolution that
has trained me not to do that so can
video games get around it I think that's
a very interesting question
Sandro stooki says what would you say is
the most important difference between
David Wallace's explanation of the born
rule in many worlds and your own I don't
think there's any important difference I
mean they're stylistically very
different but just for those who don't
know
um I wrote a paper with Charles siebens
on deriving the born rule in many worlds
uh a few years ago David Wallace and
before him David Deutsch proposed a
different way of deriving the born rule
in many worlds there are there have been
other options I I do think that you know
the the two Davids David Deutsch and
David Wallace their their evasion is
sort of what is now the standard one in
foundations of physics circles and I'd
like to think I I believe it is true but
one's personal vantage point is always
biased I think that chip siebens and my
way of thinking about it is in second
place in terms of how much attention
that it gets and the reason why we're in
second place even though there's been
many other options put on the table is
it's always really hard at the
boundaries of physics and philosophy to
correctly construct an argument for a
conclusion that you already know
right you know that what you want is the
probability of measuring something in
quantum mechanics is the wave function
squared so it's really easy to get the
right answer for the wrong reasons to
make some simple assumption that you
know seems natural to you but really
isn't that helps you get the right
answer so in the field there's a lot of
feeling that purported derivations of
the born rule are uh cheating because
they assume something that gives them
the answer rather than actually adding
it and I don't think that our solution
actually does that although opinions
might differ
the language that is used in the David
Wallace David Deutsch approach is
completely different than the language
that chip and I use which is also our
ideas based on Suggestions by Lev
Weidman and others
in the Deutsche Wallace argument you
think about what rational observers
would do you use decision Theory and use
basic features of mono mechanics to
argue that rational observers trying to
you know maximize their utility or
whatever should act as if they are going
to observe born rule probabilities in
the many worlds interpretation whereas
what chip and I say is there are
conditions of self-locating uncertainty
like so we don't use words about
decision Theory Etc we say when the wave
function branches you don't know which
branch you're on therefore you need to
assign credences to being on one branch
or another and then we argue that the
only sensible way to do that is to use
the born rule so they sound very
different
but precisely as there are many wrong
ways to get the right answer there might
also very well be equivalent right ways
of getting the right answer right when
you have a mathematical theorem and you
want to prove it it's not like there's
one correct proof and all the others are
incorrect we're very happy we said this
in the original paper we're very happy
to be compatible with other ways of
deriving the born rule we're not trying
to displace them or supplant them we're
just trying to offer a different angle
on it what I like about our way of doing
it is that to me it truly addresses and
more or less incontrovertible ways the
basic question of why there are
probabilities at all
so the Deutsche Wallace approach says
you know given that there are
probabilities of some sort I might not
know what they are but I'm going to try
to be rational and assign them in a
certain way it doesn't quite tell you
why there are probabilities in the first
place but we are crystal clear about why
there are probabilities there will be a
moment in time when you don't know what
branch of the wave function you're on
and as a good Bayesian there's an
epistemic Credence that you should be
attaching to being on one branch or the
other if you don't like our way of
deriving the born rule then that's the
the part you have to attack and people
have attacked it people you know like
David Albert will say no I don't need to
apply credences in that situation I can
just feign ignorance I can just say I
don't know what branch I'm on full stop
I think that's not a good way to do
science I don't think we do that in any
other areas of science uh so I don't
think that's that quite works that's
quite valid but um anyway I don't think
there's an incompatibility between the
two ways of doing it you know the the
Deutsch wall is approach can be
criticized on precisely the grounds that
they're making assumptions that might
not apply in particular there are
questions about how you value things
that are going on elsewhere
in particular other branches of the wave
function this there's some version of
saying that what matters to you is what
matters is what happens on your branch
not what happens on other branches and
if you if you don't buy that assumption
then you can undermine the whole game I
think that you know chip and my
self-locating uncertainty derivation
also has assumptions that you can call
into questions so uh you know at some
point I I do think that having sat
through many discussions about this
the question is not why is it the wave
function squared right that's not the
question anyone is debating so when we
say debate or derive the born rule
that's a little bit
misleading in terms of what's actually
going on what really is going on is why
is a deterministic theory having
probabilities show up at all once you
have probabilities in there and and you
admit that you should try your best to
assign probabilities in some sensible
rational way it's obviously the born
rule the born rule is just obviously
what works uh that's not where the
controversy lies the controversy is I
would argue mostly entirely
philosophical one about where the
probabilities come from where the idea
of probability comes from at all
Matt Grinder says I'm hoping you can
clarify an issue I have with the arrow
of time and the increase of entropy
suppose the universe ends in a heat
death and the hypothetical Observer
would not now perceive an arrow of time
because of the way particles now
interact do physicists mean to imply
that this would mean the time has
stopped doing what it has been doing for
billions of years namely going forward
so there's a couple things I got to like
undo the question here there are no
observers in the heat death of the
universe to be an observer requires a
departure from equilibrium so you can't
say I'm in the heat death situation and
a hypothetical Observer sees this or
that there literally are no hypothetical
observers by construction okay but we
can take the God's eye view and say like
what would the world be like and in that
case I would again undo the question
about time going forward that's not what
time does time does not go forward any
more than on the real number line the
numbers go forward there's just a an
infinite number of numbers there's the
number minus one there's the number plus
square root of two all these numbers
exist on the real number line in this
way of thinking about time the same
thing is true with time it's not the
time goes forward it's that individual
people in the part of the universe's
history where there is disequilibrium in
a strong Arrow of time per perceive time
in a certain way they perceive a passage
of time because they have a memory of
the past and predictions about the
future so the physics of time is
completely unchanged once you enter the
heat death part of the history of the
universe but the physics of observers is
changed quite dramatically namely there
are no observers and there's no
impression that time is going forward
two more questions left here in the AMA
Herbert Berkowitz says how do
fundamental particles get rather odd
names like strange and charm do the
naming rights go to the discoverer have
there been fights over who gets the
naming rights and who in the end makes
the name official
yeah it's a mess
um in astronomy things are actually much
more systematic there are Committees of
the international astronomical Union the
iau that lay down rules for naming
astronomical objects and things like
that similar like to the Committees that
decided that Pluto wasn't a planet
anymore there's a lot of committees in
astronomy but there's also a lot more
celestial objects than there are
Elementary particles so for elementary
particles they just kind of grow
organically
um in particular for both strange and
charm they had kind of long interesting
histories the idea of strangeness
as a conserved quantity came about
before the idea that there was a quark
called The Strange Quark it came about
before we knew about quarks likewise for
charm uh that was a hypothetical idea
but forward by bjorkane and clasho I
believe
um there was also the gym mechanism so
that's glashau iliopolis and mayani
maybe they said it first I forget who
said it first but there was a bunch of
theorists basically saying look we can
explain some things if you give us a
fourth Quark called the charm we're
going to call it the charm Quark because
you know they were having fun and they
turned out to be right so since they
turned out to be right people you know
went along with it other cases it's not
so clear for quarks they were
independently suggested by Gelman and
Swig George swag and Gelman suggested
calling them quarks that's why I
suggested I'm calling them Aces and
Gelman one he was more famous and it was
kind of a good name other cases
still not adjudicated there's the famous
J slash PSI particle which was
um
I'm going to get the names wrong of who
did it I believe that it was Sam Ting
who's one of the leaders of the
collaboration who found that particle
and it's it's a composite particle it's
a Meson
um and maybe Burton Richter was the
other one at slack who also discovered
it at the spear experiment and so
Richter and the slack people named it
the PSI particle Psi Psi is supposed to
be like close to spear which is the name
of the experiment that they were doing
and the J was Sam Ting's way of trying
to name it after himself because he
wanted to call it t for ting but you're
not allowed to do that so A J is very
close orthographically to a t so he
named it that
and they more or less did it at the same
time and they were both equally famous
and so nobody won so to this day it is
called the J slash PSI particle what can
you do there you go there's no
systematic way of figuring it out
final question Simon Carter says after
picking Einstein's equation as the main
subject to present from your first book
have you decided what you'll be
presenting for the second book so
there's two different ways to interpret
this question I think I know the right
way but just so everyone is on the same
track
um the books in question here are the
biggest ideas in the universe series
volume one was face time in motion and
did all of classical physics Volume 2 is
quanta and Fields and does quantum
mechanics and Quantum field Theory
uh in both books I do many topics right
there is no one main topic so just so
that is perfectly clear that would be a
misunderstanding of the question I think
what Simon is getting at is
when you write a book you go around
giving talks right you go on a book tour
the book tour thing is overrated or
overblown it's not like there's
literally a tour it's just that you know
you arrange some public docs to give and
so
I did that for the first book I will do
that for the second book The Talk that I
gave to advertise the first book was
Einstein's equation the secrets of
Einstein's equation so what that meant
is over the course of an hour I go
through the math I don't assume that you
know any calculus or anything like that
but I give you the basics of
differential geometry and gravity and
tensors and lead you up to Einstein's
equation in all of its glory and then
show you the short Shield solution Etc
and you can find versions of it online I
just recently did a version at the Royal
Institute in London Royal Institution so
I don't know if that's up yet but it
should be soon and there's other
versions floating around so yes when
book two comes out when Quantum field
comes out which will be sometime in the
spring I will need to have a talk to
give about it and I'm not sure what I
will give uh it's not going to be about
quantum mechanics
specifically I've done that right plenty
of talks I've given about that I really
want to concentrate on the quantum field
theory side of things
um
but I don't know whether I want to like
how technical I want to make it it's the
popular talk so in terms of what the
audience is it's a popular audience and
that's what I want to aim at but one way
to do it would be to talk about
Feynman diagrams and renormalization and
effective field Theory I think effective
field theory is probably the most
important idea that physicists have that
we don't tell non-physicists about so
that would be a very exciting thing to
talk about another angle to take would
be to talk about phases and gauge
theories right the coulomb phase the
Higgs phase the confinement phase how
one underlying idea of gauge symmetry
can lead to very different behavior in
very different circumstances that would
be fun to talk about I kind of did talk
about things related to that back when I
was talking about the Higgs boson in the
big in the particle at the end of the
universe book so even though it's an
important set of topics maybe it's not
the obvious one
or I could you know give the audience a
break
at the end of the book I take all that
we've learned about Feynman diagrams and
decays and so forth and I explain why
the ingredients of the universe are what
they are why we are made of protons and
neutrons and electrons held together by
electromagnetism and gravity it's a very
simple set of ingredients right three
kinds of particles protons neutrons
electrons two forces electromagnetism
and gravity that explains an enormous
amount of stuff it's not quite
everything even our everyday life it
doesn't explain nuclear fusion and
things like that how why stars shine but
still you know you and me and our
chemistry and our biology are completely
explained by that why are those the
particles that survive once heavier
particles Decay away why do you still
have neutrons hanging around even though
neutrons do Decay by themselves so I
mean that's kind of like a fun thing why
what is it where does the scale of
things come from why are atoms the size
that they are you know there's a there's
a whole bunch of things that are a
little bit less concept sexually
abstract than talking about ultraviolet
cutoffs in the renormalization group
right so that's another possibility I
don't know put your suggestions in in
the comment section here all you patreon
listeners and I will take them into
consideration we'll see one way or the
other it'll be fun I hope everyone buys
the book I hope everyone has enjoyed
this AMA thanks as always for your
support for mindscape I really
appreciate it see you next month bye bye
wow
[Music]